vous dormez
oh répondez-moi moussan vous m'avez fait
peur je m'étais assoupi où sont les
autres
les hommes jouent aux cartes dans la
bibliothèque les autres à nous disputer
tout à l'heure les femmes sont bondés ce
coucher se sont enfermés à double tour
avez vous pu prévenir quelqu'un
impossible la neige a coûté la
rochefoucauld pas le danger qu'il vienne
chez lui il a dit qu'il viendrait je
vous répète qu'il ne peut pas la route
est impraticable et le chasse neige ne
passera que demain matin
il viendra il tuera tous je vous croyais
coucher je n'arrive pas à dormir
j'ai entendu un bruit sourd comme
étouffé venant du jardin j'ai regardé
par la fenêtre mais je n'ai rien vu rien
que la neige qui tombait dieu merci tu
es nature entendu du bruit toi aussi
non tu devrais être couché non non je
suis sûr que je ne me suis pas trompé
c'est votre imagination tu travailles
personne ne troublera votre sommeil
cette nuit tient une réunion de famille
vous avez terminé votre parti oui je
veux tu professeur à plate couture il
est fou de rage alors toujours vos
histoires de briand qui vous tiennent
éveillé ce ne sont pas des histoires de
brigands on voit bien que vous n'êtes
pas d'ici c'est un malfaiteur qui est
toujours tenu parole il a tué chaque
fois qu'il l'a dit chaque fois qu'il a
posé le doigt sur une maison de ce
village il assassiné tous les occupants
pourquoi ne pas avoir prévenu la police
j'ai essayé et nous sommes tout à fait
isolé alors votre criminel ne viendra
pas ce soir à moins qu'il ne soit déjà
là impossible
j'ai fouillé la maison de fond en compte
je voulais dire parmi nous parmi nous en
aurons passé parce que vous dites
pourquoi pas après tout moi ça n'a
jamais vu personne ne sait qui il est ni
d'où il vient et pourquoi il a juré la
mort de sa vie
mais la police ne possède aucun indice
tu sais depuis bien longtemps
indique-t-on à qualité parmi les plus
sages habitants nous devons devenir d'au
delà des collines
il faut croire que ces mots contiennent
quelque chose de prophétique voix
il est mort monsieur monsieur suffoque
avec rigal est bien dit que nous
répétions oui mais moi je me sens
entendu crier alors j'ai eu peur
ultime assureurs du noir avant
alors alors pourquoi faire tout ça donne
moi quand il facile postale égard
l'action de la pièce se déroule en une
nuit d'hiver dans un chalet isolé le
montana c'est difficile de répéter en
plein soleil
c'est moi ania qui demande à nos amis de
reconstituer ici cette mise en scène
afin de gérer de plus près la réalité
abba profitons de cette interruption
pour faire une petite pause on chez
remettre vous avez été parfait je vous
en remercie et je bénis le ciel que ce
rôle n'est pas été encore disent aimer
parce que sa femme ait envie de faire
mes débuts dans la commune
permettez moi de vous dire mon cher
maître que vous êtes très très doué et
si julie à le dit vous pouvez le croire
le secrétaire perpétuelle de l'académie
française qui se prend pour un acteur
canada avant d'aller plus loin je
voudrais faire quelques remarques
si vous le permettez mon cher auteur
voilà nous en sommes à la 30e page et la
pièce vient tout juste de commencer au
moment où j'ai dit vous dormez oui selon
depuis aristophane au théâtre on n'a
jamais pu échapper à ce qu'on appelle
l'exposition mais ça c'est pas une
exposition c'est un vernissage
alors qu'est-ce que vous ne vous
demandez pas mon avis moi je vous le
donne hier je ne trouve pas ça folichon
non mais toutes les expositions semble
longue il faut il faut tout même bien
présenter les personnages au public
si vous voulez que le public comprenne
quelque chose ou alors vous en [ __ ] et
éclaire une pièce hermétique mais ça ça
n'est pas mon style et le style c'est
l'homme alors ou alors chargé un des
comédiens de jouer le rôle du coeur de
la tragédie antique
c'est à dire s'adresser directement au
public mais là messieurs vous allez voir
une pièce policière la victime
c'est le personnage qui est assis dans
ce fauteuil il ne dit rien il ne dit
rien parce qu'il est mort le personnage
qui fait au nom qui est à côté de lui
ses assassins
si on sait l'avant ce qui est l'assassin
ya plus classe policière je ne faisais
pas il y aura surtout plus de pièces
policière pour vous si moi je reprends
mon petit manuscrits sous le bras s'il
veut le porter à d'autres qu'aux médias
qui eux ne trouveront peut-être
folichonne
quel caractère d'oublier un petit peu
trop que je suis la directrice du
théâtre que nous avons signé un contrat
tous les deux
j'ai tout de même mon mot à dire enfin
toutes ces discussions
que va penser notre cher maxime la durée
sans excuser moi mon cher ami je me suis
laissé emporter et je vous prie de
m'excuser mais ces rencontres nous est
ok quand ils sont beaucoup plus sereine
mais aussi embête un peu le rythme
tandis qu'ici vous allez connaître des
moments exaltants
l'auteur va me laisser à nouveau de
retirer sa pièce la directrice va
proposer des changements qui s'avèreront
sans aucun intérêt
la vedette devait exiger d'être
affichées tout seul il mettra elle va
monter la pièce pas non plus pauvres
tout dire ça toi c'est malin le tableau
idyllique vous me mettez l'eau à la
bouche
mon cher lettre pourquoi n'avez vous
jamais écrit pour le théâtre
après ce que je viens d'entendre là que
je me le demande quand l'historien
fameux le romancier a terminé son
ouvrage il en éprouve une sorte de
soulagement mais aussi un peu de
tristesse pour lui l'aventuré terminée
pour vous elle ne fait que commencer
nous avons de l'académie deux ou trois
auteurs dramatiques
le sommet de deux roues et bien nous les
avions ou janvion secret parce qu'ils
créent les personnages de chair et d'os
ils peuvent le voir évoluer si on le
sait depuis c'est merveilleux c'est
féerique
j'ai eu tout à fait raison de vous
demander d'assister à une répétition
comme vous avez apporté votre manuscrit
d'abord ça m'a donné l'occasion de jouer
un rôle merci mademoiselle
et puis vous m'avez fait l'honneur et la
joie de venir jusqu'à mourir pour
s'arranger ravi c'était bien la moindre
des choses non oui surtout avec votre
grippe de traces oui au mali a pas d'âge
pour avoir la grippe le musée et bien
écoutez écoutez je m'en vais répondre de
deux minutes
je reviens j'ai hâte de connaître la
suite
vous voulez dire le début m un parent
bon tu peux relancé le débat sur les
expositions alors je pose ans je vous en
prie vous laisser passion amour non je
voulais dire tout à l'heure que dans
cette scène qui est bien fait bien
construite et qui a même une réelle
dimension dans quel sens l'entente u
dans le sens de la longueur naturelle
pour sa ville n'avait pas recommencer un
nous savons tous que l'action début du
vraiment à l'entrée guillaume nous
sommes tous d'accord sur ce point
alors on va pas recommencer je crois
tout de même qu'on pourrait couper un
peu dans le texte de caroline pas
pourquoi dans mon texte
pourquoi pas dans le tien mais ma chérie
ma chanson till nemec j'accepte par
avance toutes les coupures qu'on jugera
utile si elles peuvent servir la pièce
mais je ne vois vraiment pas où tout ce
que dit mon personnage est absolument
indispensable
tu trouvais pas ça folichon et à l'est
pas folichon non indispensables nuances
et c'est que je dis moi ça ne l'est pas
indispensable mais pas totalement ma
chérie excuse moi un état considérations
sur le mariage parce 19 août il n'a rien
compris c'est la clé du personnage passe
partout tout au plus mais je ne
comprends pas oui enfin tout dépend de
ce que tu en feras du personnage
évidemment pour être aidé 2 es sur ton
talent aucun ma chérie je suis
que dans la première scène tu vas être
parfait merci bien
dans la première scène joue les idiotes
alors dans ces conditions je vous
conseille de rechercher doute pour le
remplacer vous n'aurez pas de mal
il y assez de colle d'un métier de
caroline 7 avril blessé et je voulais
vraiment bien tous les deux je vous en
prie assieds toi ma cocotte ces quelques
petites coupures sont nécessaires c'est
moi qui en déciderai en accord avec
l'auteur bien entendu j'aime entendre
cette précision
nous verrons cela plus tard parce que si
on devait écouter tous les bons amis qui
vous suggère des coupures
il y aurait plus de pièces de d'autant
que je n'ai jamais rencontré deux
personnes d'accord pour couper au même
endroit lors des répétitions de ma
première pièce tu t'en souviens tu étais
déjà cessé par proche des prix j'ai
écouté tous les gens qui m'entouraient
j'ai coupé à droite à gauche à tort et à
travers croyez moi la pièce n'a rien à
gagner
moi non plus je veux dire qu est la
directrice non plus n'a rien l'année
d'ailleurs personne n'a rien de l'année
a soutenu m ainsi les quelques
spectateurs égarés qui sont venus ils
pouvaient être les deux bonnes heures la
plupart avaient déjà commencé leur nuit
ce que tu peux être amusant toi à la
ville où on va écouter l'exposition est
longue mais la pièce est courte
alors si nous commençons à un 9h10 pour
finir à 22h40 avec 20 minutes d'entracte
par les spectateurs n'auront pas pour
leur argent
mais moi je ne tiens pas du tout mais
alors du tout a volé ma clientèle j'aime
quand tu vole au secours est à clientèle
permets moi de te dire que c'est idiot
de m pourquoi ça il vaut quand même
mieux que le public soit passionné
pendant une heure et demie que le
s'embêtait pendant trois heures ils
wimille malheur avec toi ce qui n'est
pas le choix du blues ne vous discutez
pas et revenons à la pièce ah bah
justement
reprenons la lecture
je continue à lire l'euro je n'osais pas
lui demander un metteur en scène de la
plus musclée que tout à l'heure à
l'entrée de julien mazy
ma vie excuse moi de les mettre en scène
je suit même hauteur du domaine
quand j'écris un texte du mal a priori
parce que je souhaite qu'un jour on
l'entendre on passe encore tiens je ne
sais vraiment pas pourquoi j'ai écrit la
fin de la phrase parce que pour entendre
tiens c'était pas la peine que
j'écrivais alors j'aimerais l'entendre
si c'est possible c'est un média de même
tient une réunion de famille si c'est
possible
tient une réunion de famille la pièce
est heureuse et bonne raison qu'ils
allaient recommence tient une réunion de
famille vous avez terminé votre parti
oui j'ai battu le professeur à perdre
couture et les foudres ah non non non
non non c'est alors le toujours vos
histoires de brigands qui vous tiennent
et veiller au bon sens on m'a fait peur
c'est à vous m ca s'établit au pardon
toujours dans l'histoire de brigode
écrire c'est à dire et après vous fait
répéter alors toujours vos histoires de
brigands qui vous tiennent éveillé ce ne
sont pas les histoires de brigands on
voit bien que vous n'êtes pas d'ici
c'est un malfaiteur qui a toujours tenu
parole
hier tu es chaque fois qu'il l'a dit
chaque fois qu'il a posé le doigt sur
une maison de ce village je vais le
doubs à la mise en scène par doivent
chaque fois qu'il a posé le doigt sur
ses mises en jeu
la police en challenge qu'est ce que je
dis mais pourquoi ne pas avoir prévenu
la police j'ai essayé mais nous sommes
tout à fait isolé alors votre criminel
ne viendra pas ce soir à moi qu'il se
soit déjà là impossible et fouillé la
maison de faux tempère ce cerveau à
boire avant cette intervention celle
espérée entre parenthèses ne visait pas
à oui oui oui en effet je suis avant ta
boîte de rabat nos données je voulais
dire parmi nous avait prévenu max marty
comment par parmi nous mais vous ne
pensez pas ce que vous dites on va pas
après tout personne ne l'a jamais vu
personne ne sait qui il est ni d'où il
vient ni pourquoi il a juré la mort de
ce fromage tous pour villa mais la
police ne possède aucun indice
je ne puis bien longtemps un dicton
accrédités parmi les plus sages
habitants que rien de bon ne peut venir
dont delà des collines qui pour quoi que
ces mots contiennent quelque chose de
prophétique
alors là le crip je ne vais pas crier
fort pour ne pas appeler liette voilà
ne bougez pas il est mort il faut
laisser les choses en état pour la
police demain matin vous voyez il avait
raison l'assassin est parmi nous et il
n'a pas fini de tuer j'en suis sûr oh
mon dieu
personne n'a rien vu moi moi j'ai j'ai
senti quelque chose
une présence invisible impalpable et
j'ai entendu des bruits de pas sur le
tapis
on sait tous ces trucs le tapis ce bas
étage du sud
j'ai entendu des bruits bon j'ai entendu
des bruits de pas sur le tapis
moscou je me trouvais mal vous y croyez
maintenant à notre histoire de
croquemitaine oui oui je suis médium et
depuis un moment d'étranges visions
voltigent autour de moi comme des ombres
il n'y a rien dans tout cela de
surnaturel vous avez beaucoup bu et cela
excite votre imagination
c'est moi c'est moi qui donc c'est pas
ça si ce n'est pas si fort c'est moi
c'est moi qui ai inventé cette histoire
de vie lâche moore le mot body a raison
il a raison protéger nous il existe dans
cette pièce quelque chose de maléfique
je vais chercher le professeur ni de
laisser passer je ne serais pas là mais
alors je tape ça c'est pas possible
alors une petite pause ouvrir les
rideaux
non non c'est pas possible mais nous
sommes au coeur de l'action
il faudra bien sentir monter l'angoissé
la présence du professeur une
bibliothèque ce personnage que le public
ne verra jamais au lieu de rassurer doit
amener le spectateur jusqu'au frissons
voilà et parce que c'est ce que j'ai
senti en l'écrivant mais c'est parce que
j'entends en le voyant
oui mais pour m 3 semaines de
répétitions trois semaines seulement
alors tu vois ça alors ça ça me donne le
frisson et ben tu vois tu peux encore
précédé pour quelque chose
est ce que ça veut dire monsieur
messieurs bureau kde arrivé qu'au bureau
ici le critique dramatique lignac mai
mais je ne l'attendais qu'à cette heure
là quelques vérités mais les trois
heures monsieur vous à regarder à
bastille m'a dit qu'il avait rendez vous
avec monsieur oui mais à 5 heures je lui
ai dit que vous m'aviez prévenu mais que
vous ne l'attendait pas si tôt
qu'attendu
il m'a dit qu'il y avait contre autre
ordre c'est ce qu'il a dit oui mais
peut-être pas venir à 5h 9h ils auraient
pu prévenir bon nom de couteau dites lui
que je suis occupé je suis occupé sur un
train de lire heures
julien dans une pièce et je leur ai
donné que je le pourrai bien sûr de yet
installez le dans le petit salon un
millier t'installer monsieur il est allé
tout seul a il est vrai qu'il connaît le
chemin
c'est la cinquième visite protocolaire
il me rend bureau à l'académie française
on aura tout vu toto n'est pas encore
entre dit nous passons dans trois
semaines on répète oui ou non
excusez-moi mètres mais j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'on avance dans le 2 alors
d'être mal on ose y prenons le deuxième
acte sanitas débuts du duo pour les
places alors bien entendu il ya bien
entendu on saute tous monologue du début
quand tu fais chaque fois coup pendant
les répétitions au théâtre suggestions
si on coupait complètement le monologue
un merci les un vrai homme de terrain
merci de poire de proposer spontanément
ce qui s'impose et dont je n'ai pas osé
de parler jusqu'ici de couper ce
cataplasme qu'il faut que tu me prends
pour qui
tu sais très bien qu'il aurait pas
accepté ce rôle qu'il n'y avait pas le
monologue le poupée n'en est pas
question une seconde 1
parce que toi metteur en scène de génie
dans hamlet tu ferai voter
tranquillement le monologue
je te remercie en tout cas pour la
comparaison en tout cas à l'idée qu'on
puisse le coupé n'a pas eu l'air de
troubler un nom basque florent savez
très bien que julien ne se laisserait
pas amputer mais d'une seule virgule
si ce n'est pas pour défendre ton texte
j'ai engagé pourquoi alors un un acteur
de mon niveau
dans la situation actuelle voulez vous
le dire pour jouer les vedettes
il faut vous dire mon saint maxin que
bien peu d'acteurs sont capables de
résister ou analogue
parce que le monologue c'est la
consécration mais vous hissez c'est le
bâton de maréchal est bien moins chère
directrice j'ai besoin de répéter je
vais même retravaillé toute la matinée
dans le calme et la concentration va le
revoir dans le jardin mais épargnez nous
ton morceau bravo aux idiomes
ne vous énervez pas calmez vous tenez
installez-vous dans ma bibliothèque vous
y serez très bien merci beaucoup moins
cher m
ben vous en faites une tête oui mais le
soleil d'automne sera lancée les langes
de séduire 11ème et cela rend toujours
malade et je le sais vous avez gagné
égratigné dur on voulait rater oui
couvert d'insultés couvert couverts de
boue vous n'êtes pas le seul il avait
avec une telle mauvaise foi ou telle
méchanceté dans les propos que ces
articles ont relevé plus de la
diffamation de la critique
tous les auteurs maltraités au séminaire
non ça je vous assure que j'ai eu droit
vraiment à tarif préférentiel vraiment
sa manière poursuit avec une ténacité
qui ressemble à de la haine c'est parce
qu'il vous envie florent son hostilité
traduit sa rage de l'avoir jamais pu
réussir à écrire une pièce
donc nous allons voir quelque chose
j'ai demandé elle y est d'apporter du
champagne afin de baptiser votre
nouvelle
ils ne font pas tous l'arrivée de ce
monsieur jette un trouble dans leur
petite réunion on s'amusait bien charlie
en passant n'oubliez pas de servir une
coupe empoisonné à bureaux à du siffleur
nous sommes tous logés à la même
enseigne et pas toi tu ne l'as jamais si
tu es tu me l'as s'est répétée à le pire
des appeaux il m'ignore comme si je
n'existais pas il a fait une bonne
critique de la pièce de peretti
il a cité toute la distribution
jusqu'aux plus petits rôles sur la mise
en scène sur mon travail
rien comme tu aurais préféré d azur dans
les études enfin une mise en scène qui
ne se remarque pas mais c'est ce qu'on
peut réussir de mieux non heureusement
il n'est pas unique buron ses confrères
eux le m'ignore pas de bonnes critiques
j'en ai partout jusqu'au chili
quand j'ai présenté d'avoir la double
inconstance
j'ai été couverts de fleurs par l'étoile
du soir et par le soleil levant de pékin
le chinois on m'a traduit au alors quand
vous pensez bien si je me fous que plus
on ne m'aime pas senti au site ont
compris alors en revanche toit soit
jamais eu la teneur des tombes
tout part mis à rigoler ah bon parce que
tout paris rigole quand on trouve du
talent du talent tu en as bon d'accord
c'est entendu bofa du génie simplement
monsieur bur on trouve notre petite
caroline à son goût j'en suis ravi pour
toi mon nom je met l'art dramatique n'a
rien à voir là dedans
vous êtes des mufles je vous ferai
remarquer que tous les autres papiers
étaient tout aussi élogieux
alors vous allez certainement conclure
que tous ces messieurs ont envie de voir
ma chérie je les comprends de rêve alors
temps justement tu peux pas comprendre
j'ai là ton charme et compréhensible
pour tous oui toi tu l'as compris tout
de suite je suis sûr que caroline
préfére être apprécié pour ses qualités
de comédienne
je suis pour ses autres qualités est-ce
pas caroline conquis saisie via la
situation ma chère on ne sait pas si ce
temps là ah oui ça c'est vrai je suis
passé mais tu vois je me suis pas
installé
et bien moi c'est ici que je peux
m'installer
tu trouveras une autre puce elle pour me
remplacer au waziristan prix ne fais pas
ta mauvaise tête et surtout asseoir pour
qu'elle n'est jamais une bonne critique
sinon ici ça risque de déplaire je suis
on ne rend pas à tel rôle comme ça sur
un coup de tête qu'il faut le considérer
ni ne pensait pas un mot de ce qu'elle
disait sa manière bien sûr une bonne
fille née to mail faut pas exagérer non
un long couteau rejetons pris mais j'ai
embrassé vous rabaisser la féliciter
c'est la joie on pourrait demander à
bureaux de venir se joindre à nous
lucide il est excellente idée
étant donné que je ne vivrai pas un
général l'euro comment vous ne vivrez
pas a sûrement pas il déteste ce genre
de pièce puis je n'ai pas du tout envie
de voir ce monsieur de mon théâtre et
bien voilà ce que nous pouvons par un
dernier au public de venir
il s'emploie bien tout seul à ma
connaissance pourtant vous n'avez jamais
eu personnellement avons plein d'appétit
qu aux gens du matin à flot oui mais
dans le temps mais l'académie a ceci de
grosses séquelles vous met quasiment à
l'abri
la miilos par match mais permettez vous
êtes allé me refaire une beauté et que
money quel luxe inutile
vous êtes toujours charmant maxime mais
laissez moi passer quand même
oui mais qu'on use et même jusqu'à
samedi à propos de buron il ya une
anecdote qui me vient à l'esprit
je ne résiste pas au plaisir de vous la
conter il y a quelques années il a rendu
visite à un de mes confrères un concours
et il lui a dit à peu près ceci je n'ai
aucune chance de voir le prix mais je
vous demande de voter comme au premier
tour sa manière je l'aurais qu'une fois
mais ça me fera chaud que de penser que
c'est là vous seriez pas là qu'on rit
alors mon copain c'est de réfléchir et
le jour du dépouillement tous les bons
coups et le débours bureau parce qu'il
avait fait la même démarche au point de
tous les académiciens
ce sera pour une autre fois il a fallu
procéder au vote quel canal quel culot
de votre obligé parce que sans lui vous
florent sans lui vous continueriez
d'écrire mais sans vous lui il ne rirait
plus c'est vous qui lui donné
l'importance
en tout cas je ne vois pas ce qu'il y
aurait de scandaleux à ce qu'il soit
reçu un jour sous la coupole
il mérite tout de même mieux d'y siéger
que le duc demi branche qui brident le
même fauteuil et dont personne n'a
jamais lu à ce livre voudront lui au
moins il écrit bien les cris vient buron
un jargon incompréhensible un charabia
dit-on à propos de charabia
alors là revenons à ta pièce il ya des
phrases qui est impossible à dire
qu'elles ont des armées c'est qu'ils y
va d'un ski au téléphone à excuser moi
mon cher m c'est la peine que
j'attendais donc je vous avais parlé
c'est beaucoup plus tranquille
merci voilà c'est pas me raser nous mais
écoute moi ça c'est la jarre en congés
qui a jeté la caissette de se casser
c'est quoi ça basescu est triste c'est
l'agent aux congés qui a jeté la
question des 7,4 c'est impossible à dire
sur elle même et au cou jamais aucun
acteur ne pourra dire comme ça d'une
façon désinvolte à vous savez c'est là
j'ai rencontré trois fois et très bien
oui mais c'est pas moi qui le dit dans
la pièce assez a dit si bien jean
autre chose qu est ce que tu veux
désagréable on ne peut jamais parlé avec
toi je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mot sur maxime mais vraiment on ne me
demandez pas trop reparti je voudrais
pour rien au monde mini c'est dans vos
petites querelles et ça c'est pas moi
qui l'ait qui vous inquiétez pas mon
cher ami on se querelle comme ça mais en
réalité on s'adore le théâtre j'ai une
grande famille alala les atrides
messieurs monsieur c'est la police mais
oui à l'inspecteur qui demandent si
c'est ici que se tient la réunion à sa
cause devant la réunion d'auteuil
en tout cas il dit que c'est très
sérieux et ben faites entrez entrez
monsieur grâce à la bouche il est
important que chacun reste à sa place et
n'utiliser de sortir la maison cernée
aimé avons l'ordre tiraient plutôt de
vous mon cher maître je vous présente
andré lambert un comédien de notre
troupe qui va jouer le rôle de
l'inspecteur dans ma pièce et dont les
facéties de seconde que vous m'avez
réellement impressionné monsieur j'ai le
coeur fragile
je sais pas comment m'excuser mais elles
n'ont pas non plus ne serait-il pas
c'est plutôt bien au menu genevois dit
bonjour ma chérie mais la foi
au honduras et remix à bao di dio
vivions tandja n'est pas débordé la
victoire au bout et julien il est là tu
peux dire c'est que j'ai besoin tout le
monde est aussi dans la distribution et
qu'on cesse manon justement il reste
encore 1 euro la distribuer et nous
passons dans trois semaines à venir
tu as eu une réponse de fedor il mène en
bateau ne le fera pas je suis persuadé
qu'elle devra bon rythme alors là tu
rêves ils me doivent au coûteux devrait
même encore davantage que ça ne
changerait pas grand chose ou est ce que
tu as entendu parler de reconnaissance
au théâtre leurs connaissances c'est une
qualité de chiens c'est pas une qualité
cabot g de toit sont guillaume je crois
que je viens à raison parce que depuis
qu'il a tourné trois films faits d'or à
la tête comme ça je les trouvais mauvais
quand son dernier free and on and on me
dit pas mauvais pas mon verre très bon
et le puits n'a reçu aucune proposition
rien mais non et pourtant il paraît
qu'il est chez lui toute la journée
ainsi pas son téléphone soit de petites
chaises
mettez-vous à sa place tous les copains
de sa génération sont fait un nom au
cinéma ça me rend malade
on voit si tu veux mon avis d'intention
fedor été les fois dans tout de suite à
un bon deal à part ce sera dans la place
c'est un vrai robinet d'eau qui avoue
divers dérange c'est solide ça s'est
tellement solide que ça vous assomme on
ne sont relève le rôle déjà votre feu la
madjer addip qui est acculé à la
faillite ne fait pas et qui au mieux
avec isaac odinga ce sera le mur des
lamentations bon je vous laisse
réfléchir tâcher de trouver un nom je
vous demande la permission d'aller
demander un verre d'eau à eliette parce
que j'ai un médicament à prendre je
connaissais je me planque
que diriez-vous de doucet ah ça c'est
l'idée du jour pouvait pas plus mal
tomber
alors vraiment le contraire du rôle
admettons que j'ai rien dit
puis tout c'est une règle s'affiche au
dessus du titre à sa wii ait mme banon
l'euro ne justifie pas son talent en
double c'est en effet là avec la valeur
ridicule il est très bien
selon chaque fois qu'on avance le monde
elle aussi vite qu'ils trouvent quelque
chose à ça je sais très bien que tu les
trouves toi adou c'est un bon vous
disputez pas on sait ma chérie que tu as
eu des faiblesses pour lui mais c'est de
l'histoire ancienne tout ça ah bon
d'accord parce que tout fait aussi au
tout ça le flanc alors là je te demande
vraiment pardon car lille où julien tu
vas pas être jaloux rétrospectivement du
tout les amendes caroline mais on n'en
sortira jamais car alors là vraiment me
dit tu exagères caroline écoute ça y est
maintenant la série non leurs pattes à
brochure c'est qu'est ce que tu cherches
et je te ferai pas ce plaisir je
resterai je voulais pas du tout le faire
de peine cette idiote veut que sur quoi
dire non si je peux me permettre de
digressions il ya un acteur que j'aime
beaucoup moi c'est granier c'est
inversement
je ne sais pas si l'euro lui
conviendrait j'avais pensé à lui en tout
premier lieu mais c'est impossible
et pourquoi il voudrait pas non c'était
pas ça mais si nous prenons granier nous
perdons lisbeth caron ils sont fâchés à
mort
et comme l'ami de mademoiselle caron
ordre pour prendre pour ça dans mon
affaire
les temps sont trop difficiles pour que
je puisse supporter seul les risques
d'une telle entreprise
vous pensez ma team il me manque encore
10 % oui vous voulez dire un associé à
10%
mais leur exactement un associé à 10%
mais je ne vois pas la wii ça se voit
oui pourquoi c'est dès lors difficile de
trouver des associés pour une entreprise
déroulent à la salle devient mon cher m
vous connaissez beaucoup de pigeons vous
qui veulent entrer dans une affaire en
étant seulement intéressé aux déficits à
penser à jamais de bénéfices mais si
beaucoup beaucoup
pour le directeur pour le producteur
jamais où le sort de polytechnique mais
il ya là
rythme éthique mais ne l'écouté pas
n'importe quoi pour essayer de me faire
passer pour une fripouille
maintenant ce qu'il oublie de vous dire
c'est que enfin les associés reçoivent
chaque semaine des comptes scrupuleux et
qu'il vous sera très facile de vérifier
vous même
oh mercy maxime alors la merci beaucoup
vraiment le ah bon je vous souhaite de
diriger un théâtre à vous aurez bien du
plaisir
alors vous faites à crocheter membres
mais que refuse toutes les offres qui te
sont faites pas bien sûr elles sont
dérisoires
si ça vaut tellement cher c'est que ça
rapporte gros courbon beaucoup d'ambert
damman boudaud maire de man qu'on aura
une autre habilleuse enfin je sens déjà
paré et la pauvre lucienne ne peut pas
tout faire et surtout ne tient plus
debout tu sais c'est pas avec ce qu'elle
gagne qu'elle peut manger de la viande
tous les scouts ou verra on verra
policière faisait tous ça on verra on
verra qu'on va flanqué spectacle partir
parce que j'aurai raté mes entrées
j'ai des changements rapides si je
voulais faire tout seul en soutenant
lucienne par-dessus marché alors là on
vous réserve la raison et au sujet de
l'accessoiriste tu t'es décidé à enfin
son régisseur peut pas faire tout tout
seul non voyons il te fait tard et j y
te fais tes courses y repas dès lors il
est dit-on mais qu'est ce que tu dois
bien lui faire pour qu'il te sois si
dévoués bah rien du tout alors je me
demande bien quand on bat pourront
revenu à la distribution pourquoi pas
bernard violet à je lui ai téléphoné il
m'a répondu je cite qu'il cherchait une
pièce qui lui permettent de se plonger
dans une créativité qui ait valeur de
communication à qu'il avait besoin de se
revitaliser au contact d'éléments
susceptibles de lui apporter un plus
grand panorama
alors j'ai vacanciers elle s'arrête et
excité au contraire que qui nous a
rebattu les oreilles toutes ces
sornettes python l'histoire actor studio
andrée andré tu ne savais pas mais
guillaume a terminé sa crise non il a
réintégré la grande famille du théâtre
de boulevard la famille du théâtre des
demeurés
toute façon nos jours dans un théâtre
donc nous n'aurions pas eu bernard
violet voudrait-il dans le jouet sa
jeune homme clamé partout partout sauf
dans un théâtre
mais les préférences dans un hangar ah
oui et un lieu où mieux maxime mieux un
espace vide
le plus souvent il à propos de vide est
avant que quelqu'un d'autre n'établisse
la comparaison si on revenait à la
lecture de ma pièce mais je ne crois que
votre travail précieux montchanin bon
ami à mon art un peu plus tôt un peu
plus tard cela vraiment aucune
importance si vous voulez reprenons
simplement la fin d'une nouvelle fois et
après j'ai quitté dirait buron puisque
sa présence vous est désagréable ce ne
soit pas alors voilà bon alors on
reprend bat julien turquoise à sortir on
va rappeler je vais chercher le
professeur ne laissez pas seuls
non je ne serai pas là c'est ça les
oublier que je suis là nous n'avons rien
à craindre tant que nous resterons tous
ensemble et surtout si si l'assassin
dans la maison pourquoi le professeur
n'était pas avec nous c'est un homme
étrange
il me fait peur pourquoi il y avait vu
demander de venir mois j'ignorais son
existence jusqu'à ce soir
mais alors pourquoi
le professeur mais quoi le professeur il
est mort on l'a assassiné monsieur
monsieur monsieur virant monsieurbureau
quoi monsieur murray on parle il est
mort on l'assassiné
personne n'a rien vu
moi moi j'ai senti quelque chose
une présence invisible impalpable déjà
entendu des bruits de pas sur le tapis
c'est quoi sinon trouver mal vous y
croyez maintenant à notre histoire de
croquemitaine oui je suis médium et
depuis un moment des transmissions
voltigent autour de moi comme des ombres
à il n'y a rien dans tout cela le
surnaturel
vous avez beaucoup bu et cela excite
votre imagination c'est moi c'est moi
qui ai inventé cette histoire de village
maudit 1 il a raison protégez nous il
existe dans cette pièce quelque chose de
magnifique
je vais chercher le professeur mais ne
laissez pas ça se vende une seconde je
crois que c'est là qu'on s'était arrêté
si on est certain c'est à huy julien
raison à oui c'est exact nous nous
étions arrêtés car eliette était venu à
nous c'est un mec on s'en est créé la
limite durant gauche le ballon quand il
y était entré ne l'étions déjà
interrompu à bouche c'est l'art en gaz
il me semble et sparrow charrie tout ça
s'est brouillée dans ma mémoire à vous
avez ce drame chez moi et puis la
réalité a suivi de cyprès l'action de
votre pièce logo j'en ai été bouleversé
genève n'est plus même impressionné
excusez moi monsieur mais ne me demandez
pas plus c'est moi qui vous prie de
m'excuser mon cher maître de vous avoir
demandé de prendre part à cette
reconstitution je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté c'est tout naturel
auriez-vous c'est la première fois que
je me trouve en face d'un académicien au
milieu d'une troupe de comédiens je dois
dire que je suis moi même un peu
déconcerté vous ne donnez pas du tout
l'impression commissaire il faut pas se
fier aux apparences malin vous disiez
monsieur que vous ne vous êtes pas
arrêtée à cause de l'arrivée de monsieur
buron pourquoi alors avez-vous
interrompu votre lecture c'est moi qui
voulais donner quelques indications aux
comédiens pour une meilleure confiance
la pièce a il comprenait pas c'est parce
que je veux dire je vais parler de la
psychologie des personnages de la façon
de les aborder de les concevoir
je voulais leur faire part à ce sujet de
quelques réflexions personnelles par
exemple je me souviens pas exactement
six ans quand d'importance aux roms
croyez pas ça comprenez bien que tous
vous entendez bien tout peut m'être
utile le plus petit détail peut être un
indice au moment du meurtre vous étiez
bien tout se placer comme tout à l'heure
on line
tu n'étais pas au jardin comment
mam'zelle vous étiez dans le jardin pour
cette répétition c'est du jargon
théâtrale au jardin cela veut dire à
droite regardant le public et la course
et de l'autre côté a passé comme tribord
et bâbord dans la marine et d'où
viennent ces traditions de louis callens
commissaire quand on jouait à hot wheels
ri devant le roi est bien à gauche se
trouvait la cour d'honneur et à droite
les jardins cuite et pendant la
répétition
nous avions imaginé le public là voilà
c'est à dire la raison pour laquelle
voyez les meubles disposer ainsi gelé
quand on répète on imagine toujours
qu'il ya du public en face quand on joue
il a plu mais alors bon débat et à quel
moment la gouvernante tel annoncé
l'arrivée de la victime mais fleuron
viens de vous le dire commissaire nous
venions juste de nous interrompt moselle
il y est
mademoiselle eliette voulez vous avoir
la gentillesse de refaire les mêmes
gestes de prononcer les mêmes paroles
qu'avant-hier envie de l'essayer
je vous remercie allons-y 7 10 mois vous
allez vous et bien ce centre et parle
alors je sors
monsieur c'est la police rouillé vous
venez annoncé à votre maître l'arrivée
de monsieur durand o
excusez-moi j'ai tellement aimé je sais
juste que je serais moi non ne sortait
pas inutile à écouter monsieur sy soir
offert comme avant-hier mois seront
faits comme avant-hier
alors je sors monsieur monsieur viron
viens d'arriver je lui ai dit que vous
n'attendiez pas si tôt mais il m'a dit
contre ordre il s'est installé dans le
petit salon
voilà j'ai l'impression d'entendre la
lecture d'un télégramme enfin
l'essentiel y est
et il était bien trois heures et
monsieur bur on avait rendez vous à 5h
tête exact mais il a prétendu que vous
aviez avancer l'heure de votre rendez
vous
c'est ce qu'elle y est t'as compris
j'imagine m que vous devez avoir
beaucoup de choses en tête
à ceci que vous auriez très bien pu
oublier un coup de téléphone à monsieur
buron l'entrevue avec lui n'étant pas
d'une importance capitale pour vous
j'imagine je n'ai rien oublié du tout
monsieur et même si j'avais eu une
petite absence peut être insistant sur
vite remis les choses en place
envoyez-vous j'essaie de ne rien
négliger pour ne pas orienter au départ
mon enquête dans une mauvaise direction
mais j'avais compris je vous remercie
bien
eliette est sorti
que s'est-il passé ensuite bien que nous
avons bavardé comme d'habitude de quoi à
bâtons rompus
comme d'habitude rompus sur le dos de
bureau comme d'habitude et oui le pauvre
il n'a vraiment pas eu de chance
ne vous gênez pas pour moi je sais très
bien qu aucun d'entre vous n'avez une
raison particulière de le porter dans
son coeur
de là à le tuer bizier monsieur bur on
était venu vous voir dans l'espoir
d'entrer à l'académie française
oui c'est nous appelons cela monsieur
une visite protocolaire avait-il une
chance je ne crois pas elle devait
pouvoir en tout cas penser compter sur
votre voix j'imagine je l'imaginé en
effet avait il tort questions
indiscrètes
vous avez raison excusez moi ne me suis
laissé entraîner m'enfin pouvez vous me
dire quelle a été la réaction des
personnes présentes ici
pour ce qui me concerne j'avoue que j'ai
été assez surpris je ne m'attendais pas
à cette candidature bah pourtant la
presse l'avait mentionné
je ne lis pas les jambes je me suis
livrée d'ailleurs à aucun commentaire
j'ai simplement fait part à notre autre
de mon étonnement je n'aimais pas buron
c'est de notoriété publique
mais je ne lui ai jamais nié un certain
talent
je regrettais simplement qu'il ait mis
son talent au service de ce que je
considère comme une mauvaise cause
parler de la critique en général ou
celle de vous qui vous concerne et plus
particulièrement je parle en général
j'ai fait rechercher tous les articles
que buron vous a consacré à tous ces
dernières années je vous trouve
particulièrement indulgent ce sont
autant d'appels au marteau geslin
dossier qu'on pourrait baptiser
circonstances atténuantes à la limite
vous et vous pourrez dire que vous étiez
presque tous en état de légitime défense
a il est vrai que parfois sa plume était
plus dangereuse la revolver mais c'est
la règle du jeu
le commissaire il faut l'accepter on va
fâcher l'impression d'un jeu où les dés
sont pipés où les atouts sont toujours
dans la même a pas souvent l'occasion
d'aller au théâtre
enfin j'ai eu l'année dernière des
billets à prix réduit pour aller voir
votre pièce l'étoile filante un titre
prédestiné ben écoutez moi j'avais passé
une très bonne soirée
néanmoins si je peux me permettre petite
réserve j'avais beaucoup aimé la fin
enfin je viens de lire la critique de
monsieur buron je la trouve très
exagérées merci alors je suis très
sincère écoutez franchement quand je lis
vous avait mitonné un avec re dans un
ragoût débile en l'assaisonnant de
dialogue de garçons de bain
c'est ce portrait
faux seins ni pour les garçons de bain
un idiot je vous remercie en tout cas de
m'en avoir rappelé les termes exacts
l'eau c'est très exagéré mois sera vous
me serais restée sur l'estomac par vous
j'ai eu des crampes en effet mais
j'estime que le mépris est un remède
plus salutaire que la vengeance vous
avez raison clan monsieur en littérature
les injures les plus graves sont la
plupart du temps réglé par l'oubli mais
je me rends pas bien compte en tout cas
monsieur rumba vais pas parler
particulièrement sensible au talent de
mademoiselle ans ce n'est que justice
caroline a beaucoup de talent elle le
mérite bien
c'est ce que nous disions tous
avant-hier si je peux me permettre moi
aussi de donner mon avis je vous ai vu
mademoiselle la semaine dernière à la
télévision dont je ne sais plus quelle
bêtise vous étiez très bien
merci monsieur le commissaire vous avez
dû faire des progrès rapides
je ne sais pas peut-être pourquoi je
trouverai pas parce que j'ai là deux
critiques de monsieur buron d'été de
l'année dernière t'es pas
particulièrement tendres tendres ils
n'avaient pas su déceler apparemment le
jeune talent qui était en venant fesser
vient de le reconnaître maintenant vous
le connaissiez comme ça je l'avais
rencontrée par ci par là dans des
endroits publics à des général nous
avions échangé quelques mots quelques
mots donc conversation d'ordre général
sur la critique est sûre buron en
particulier lequel est là dans la pièce
à côté
rêvant peut-être qu'il va devenir
immortel est le moment ou jamais
alors que son assassin est ici dans
cette pièce commissaire vous voulez dire
parmi nous c'est exact vous plaisantez
monsieur pas du tout m l'un de nous un
assassin à côté voilà une idée amusante
je ne trouve pas chère madame
voyez vous j'ai bien étudié la
topographie des guildes par
invraisemblable que l'assassin soigneux
l'extérieur vous qui pâtissent et des
histoires policières il y avait
certainement déjà pensé il ya très loin
de la réalité à la fiction
et pour la première fois que j'y plonge
et en direct dans la vérité j'avoue que
je ne me suis pas posé de questions vous
me surprenez vous concocté dans votre
cabinet des intrigues policières
compliqué vous semblait indifférent
kohout trouver en face d'eux problèmes
concrets votre opinion mon cher collègue
pas très gentil pour moquer de moi je ne
me moque pas là la fonction crée
l'organe pourquoi le rôle ne craint-il
pas la vocation et vous interprétez des
commissaires des policiers des
détectives des inspecteurs et le
physique monsieur le commissaire nhtsa
j'ai jamais pu en sortir
j'ai débuté dans arsène lupin mais le
rôle du sien grandes villes
quand on pense à moi c'est toujours pour
un flic à j'ai bien essayé au début de
ma carrière de mentir et j'ai même
refusé deux rôles dans des films
policiers
quand je me suis rendu compte qu'on
m'appellerait jamais pour proposer
tromper un autre personnage m j'ai
réintégré la police qu est ce que vous
les feuilles bien que je me fasse je
serai flic tout mag
d'autant que physiquement vous êtes
beaucoup plus crédible que moi vous ne
vous en preniez pas aussi on aime
beaucoup la grande maison à ça c'est
vrai alors j'ai pas payer une seule
contravention depuis la quête de tout
d'ailleurs dans la rue les flux clé les
agents me reconnaissent et 10 à lui
bénéficier de tous les avantages de
notre profession sans en connaître les
inconvénients vous gravissez les
échelons de la hiérarchie finirait
préfet de police
oui à l'ancienneté puis je vous posais
une question commissaire nous employer
madame vous avez dit tout à l'heure
qu'il était peu probable que l'assassin
soit venu de l'extérieur
pourquoi trois raisons la première c'est
qu'il est très difficile d'entrer dans
la propriété sans se faire remarquer le
portail est muni d'un oeil électronique
et eliette surveille toutes les entrées
et les sorties
c'est exact on peut sauter le mur avec
une petite échelle sont pas dire
impossible
je dis très difficile d'entrer sans se
faire remarquer encore plus d'en sortir
deuxièmement pourquoi l'assassin soit il
vu commettre son forfait ici pour faire
de chacun de nous un suspect ou c'était
prendre de bien gros risques
troisièmement il aurait fallu qu'il soit
au courant de la visite de monsieur bur
ont en tout cas personne d'entre nous
ici n'était au courant de cette visite
c'est vous qui le dites non je peux vous
affirmer monsieur veut vous avions mais
affirmé que dix ont tous manifesté la
plus grande surprise en apprenant cette
visite et moi le premier d'ailleurs
parce que je l'attendais deux heures
plus tard mon cher maître ne fait pas
injure à vos amis ce sont tous
d'excellents comédiens pour qui
simulaient la surprise est un jeu
d'enfant on n'y avait pas passer à côté
comme ici à je dois dire au nom de tous
mes camarades que je trouve vos
insinuations fort déplaisante ne vous
fâchez pas même je croyais que dans
votre métier ont pratiqué un certain
sens de l'humour
depuis j'essaie de ne pas dramatiser la
situation oh mais les journalistes ne
partage pas votre sentiment monsieur
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on aime qu'on a
le critique assassine et ce décès
de l'académie française jamais vous
pouvez pas y échapper c'est de
l'information issa celui ce sens cette
information bon du rififi quai conti du
rouge sur un habit vert
une question que de moi le contenu vous
l'emballage
il s'attaque à ma vie privée et bien
c'est bart monsieur c'est immonde
c'est répugnant non soyez tranquilles il
n'épargne personne
vous ne pourrez jamais arrêter les
divagations de journalistes avides de
sensations uniques aux médias en mal de
publicité d'aller se montrer à la
télévision
ces moments depuis dix ans absolument
j'ai donc insensé de profiter de la
situation pour aller parader à la télé
si encore tu veux parler de la pièce
bien alors j'en ai parlé ça a été coupée
ce n'est pas ma faute
bon et puis alors si je suis allé à la
télé c'est parce qu'on m'a demandé moi
j'ai été sollicité moi aussi figure toi
mais j'ai refusé j'ai pas moins question
de décence oh merci madame la directrice
voilà une leçon de modestie à laquelle
qui nous a pas habitués à angers temps
prix julien tout cas moi je vous
félicite chère madame je l'est justement
vous demandez à tous la plus grande
discrétion pendant le déroulement de
l'enquète et de ne vous prêter à aucune
interview coûté commissaires pourraient
ce que vous voudrez après ça je peux
même vous promettre que l'un d'entre
vous race à photographier en première
page de tous les journaux
bon revenons à nos moutons plus quand
monsieur durand avait t-il sollicité
sans débat c'est à moi oui c'était le
jour de la séance du dictionnaire
monsieur laquelle mon état de santé ne
permettait pas d'assister le fait que
ben hur on m'appelle ce jour là chez moi
ça va mais ça n'avait frappé c'était
donc je dis ya cinq jours jusqu'à preuve
du contraire
puis je me permettre ça mais je vous en
prie mon cher collègue
merci si dur on a été assassiné avec le
revolver de mettre sinclair il fallait
donc le meurtrier sache où étaient
rangés à c'est une déduction qui
s'imposent et le penon s'agir que d'un
familier et j'ai jamais dit que ce
revolver est l arme du crime j'ai dit
qu'il s'agissait d'un 6 35 et que
c'était avec une arme de ce type que la
victime avait été retenu ah oui alors
même si si si on peut même se demander
précisément à quoi il manque une balle
dans le chargeur de cette arme
seul m sinclair problèmes aux tirs
malheureusement il se souvient plus je
peux plus je vais 7,1 me depuis très
longtemps dans un tiroir de secrétaire
je m'en étais jamais servi la maison est
très isolé alors vous dire si le
chargeur était complet et aussi bien à
cap et vous ne vous souvenez pas non
plus si cette arme était à sa place au
début de la compétition
l'idée de le vérifier le mot n'est pas
venu je ne pouvais pas avoir besoin
supposée en tout cas avoir besoin d'une
arme l'occasion de cette réunion amicale
mais c'est là sous les papiers sa seule
présence suffisait de me donner à 100
monder sécurité et personne non plus n'a
entendu la moindre détonations
l'assassin dû servir d'un silencieux
il fallait l'adapter à l'armée par
conséquent en connaître la nature sont
c'est pas grave nous serons tout c est
comment également expliqué que cette
armée pu se retrouver dans le tiroir
simple détail des deux mises en scène à
la sas a très bien pu la placer dans des
terroirs du bureau en profitant de
l'affolement et du désordre qui ont dû
s'installer après l annonce de la
découverte du meurtre qui s'est approché
de ce bureau noir moi je me suis
approché du bureau je voulais prendre
mon sac que j'avais envie de de fumer
une cigarette dans un pas et le moment
oui c'est toujours dans ces moments-là
que j'éprouve le besoin de fumer et vos
camarades s'étaient tous précipités dans
le petit salon vous étiez donc seul
devant ce blu non monsieur sinclair y
était déjà
mais que faisiez-vous je cherchais le
numéro de téléphone de la gendarmerie de
rambouillet que j'avais noté sur mon
agenda
avant même de savoir si elle y est
s'était trompé réécoutez commissaire je
ne souhaitais pas très savante mais
quand je vois un homme les yeux grands
ouverts avec du sang plein la tête
je me doute quand même qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose de pas très normal non
en effet mais reprenons l'ordre
chronologique qui d'entre vous est
sortie pendant la répétition mois moi je
suis allé dans la bibliothèque la
conversation de vos camarades nous
ennuyait on pas du tout commissaire mais
j'avais besoin de revoir mon texte avant
la suite de la répétition
j'ai un long tunnel aux 2,1 quoi un
tunnel un monologue en termes
professionnels
en tout cas je rends hommage à votre
belle conscience professionnelle non
merci comme ils serrent vous savez le
talent ne suffit pas potosi beaucoup de
travail moule mais julien n'a pas quitté
la bibliothèque comme sert comme on le
savait où nous l'avons tous entendue
n'est ce pas il n'a pas cessé de dire
son rôle va c'est la dernière édition du
journal du soir monsieur à il ya du
nouveau cra pour tirer à vue à inventer
encore les lieux le crime mais comment
tu fais pour prendre les photos de ce
salon mais non monsieur ça m'étonnerait
que ce soit les mêmes vous dirigez est
mort ça monsieur il ya trois ans vous
n'aviez pas encore le masque vaudou
kellogg's des livres vous souvenez vous
vous la fait ramener en février en même
temps quoi de la barre oui c'est vrai à
la raison et puis si vous voulez mon
avis eh bien ces deux photos elles ont
été prises hier matin par ici et c'était
justement en train de faire le ménage et
pas regarder là on voyait bout du tuyau
de l'aspirateur et bâtonnets c'est à peu
près au moment l'inspecteur est venu que
l'inspecteur a expliqué nous sommes
heureuses et et bien hier matin un homme
est venu il m'a dit qu'il était
inspecteur de police et qu'il venait de
votre part j'ai envoyé personne enfin
s'il n'a montre une carte mais il m'a
dit qu'il venait pour pour les photos
d'identité judiciaire et même que
c'était pas la peine de déranger
monsieur qui est encore dans sa chambre
si je comprends bien on m'a trompé non
mais moi je trouvais pas ça parce que
c'est pas votre route vous n'avez rien à
vous reprocher mais c'est
invraisemblable âgées soins dans le
rappelle le préfet n'en fait rien mais
vous ne pourrez pas empêché un
photographe pour un journaliste de
déguiser en bonne soeur en plombier ou
en policier pour parvenir à ses fins
l'amour y est que pour pas être
importuné vous aviez couper votre ligne
oui mais j'en ai une seconde vie n'était
pas que personne ne connaît d'ailleurs
en outre presque personne à l'académie
ma famille et quelques amis
si monsieur monsieur mon éditeur
justement merci m alors allons pas bon
oui bon bain à peu près oui oui vous
avez lu la presse c'est scandaleux
vous avez c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
je partage pas du tout votre sentiment à
monsieur mais non les pros question mais
jamais je ne me prêterai cette mascarade
non non non non non non non je n'ai pas
eu besoin jusqu'à un temps de publicité
malsaine pour faire venir des femmes au
revoir et iec tiendra non
non ne savais pas que ma prends mon
éditeur et bien que les libraires se
jette sur mon dernier sait pas oui oui
non ils connaissaient n'est pas assez
difficile d'ailleurs oui alors il m'a
proposé un nouveau tirage un nouveau
tirage et le bande annonce d'un loup
tout à fait douteuse
je vous demande vraiment si je ne vis
pas un cochon en remettez vous mon cher
mais non monsieur est ce que vous aviez
vous en avez pas longtemps parce que moi
je voudrais aller me reposer quelques
minutes encore si vous le permettez j'ai
besoin de savoir qui d'entre vous est
sorti et votre témoignage à tous mais
très précieux monsieur le commissaire
moi je me souviens c'est j'ai conduit ma
dame à la salle de bain oui en effet en
effet c'est exact oui j'avais demandé à
monsieur s'acquiert la permission
d'aller me le refaire une beauté
quand j'aurai même a ajouté cet effet
luxe inutile à vous êtes toujours
charmant maxime ça vous a pris longtemps
que vous êtes galant commissaire
ce n'est pas une réflexion que je vous
fais que c'est une question que je vous
pose un décor mais je suis incapable de
vous répondre je ne sais pas moi cinq
minutes enfin à 10 peut-être mais vous
n'avez rien vu rien entendu
non je n'ai rien vu rien entendu je suis
désolé commissaire lorsque vous êtes
revenu dans ce salon avez vous remarqué
s'il manquait quelqu'un à 6,6 et
guillaume est on prêt lorsque je suis
sorti on te demander au téléphone enfin
je crois
ah oui oui en effet je me souviens
j'avais conduit monsieur téléphone louis
qui vous téléphonez ses personnels
d'être resté longtemps absent je pense
que oui mon correspondant et rabat
l'identité de votre correspondant est ce
indispensable à mon avis oui oui bien
sûr vous pouvez refuser de me répondre
enfin tôt ou tard je le saurai j'imagine
ce était l'adjoint au maire du vésinet
il y avait une réunion du conseil
municipal au sujet de la future maison
de la culture
je suis bien placée pour être nommé
directeur et j'avais demandé qu'on me
téléphona le résultat alors aucune
décision n'a été prise
vous avez donc encore toutes vos chances
je pense que oui surtout maintenant que
bureau est mort voulez vous dire ceci
l'année dernière à la même époque
la presse avait annoncé un peu
prématurément semble-t-il votre
nomination à comtoise un poste similaire
j'ai là un petit article signé de
monsieur buron il ya quelques lignes
vous concernant je cite pour la santé
morale et un équilibre cérébrale des
habitants du val d'oise
la nomination au poste de directeur de
la future maison de la culture du plus
inexistant des metteurs en scène
il parle de vos merci serré espérons
qu'il s'agit d'une fausse nouvelle est
que les édiles concernés choisir
homme de théâtre qui soit capable
lorsqu'il ouvre un manuscrit de
comprendre ce qu'il lit fin de citation
vous le connaissez pas très gentil pour
vous sympa même si c'est vrai alors la
commissaire vous allez un peu fort
je crois vous m'avez mal compris je
voulais dire que même si le pensait il
ya une façon de dire des choses moins
brutale - blessantes oui mais buron
était un homme odieux et cruel à la
suite de quoi ton naturellement les
conseillers municipaux vous en laisse
est sans nouvelles à la suite de quoi
tout naturellement j'ai trucider buron
pour qu'il ne renouvelle pas au vésinet
son exploit trottoir c'est vous qui le
dis c'est pas moi non mais vous pensez
je pense à tout monsieur donc c'était un
certain temps que téléphone je suis
revenu en même temps que caroline
j'allais refermé la porte quand elle est
entrée
alors bon vous aussi mademoiselle vous
étiez sortie où étiez vous à les
désigner comme celle
j'attendais pour cela le retour de ma
directrice
mais si vous aviez vu ou entendu quelque
chose je vous le dirai d'ailleurs je me
suis absenté très peu de temps vous me
disiez monsieur vous êtes revenu en même
temps que mademoiselle par la même porte
c'est exact laquelle est celle ci il ya
une imposte sur une petite table dans le
couloir là je téléphonais mademoiselle
quand vous êtes rendus à la salle de
bains par où êtes-vous sorti par ici
commissaire alors pourquoi êtes vous
revenu par là pas le plus court chemin
oui je m'étais perdu j'ai en fait
j'avais perdu mon chemin à ses dons ça
donc chacun d'entre vous est sorti à un
moment quelconque sauf vous ce monsieur
non je suis sorti également je suis allé
à la cuisine demandé un verre d'eau à
elle y est je me suis rendu directement
la paille
vous connaissez bien la maison haut
depuis de nombreuses années j'ai
l'honneur d'être l'ami de monsieur
sinclair et à part vous une personne
d'autre n'était venu dans cette maison
avant cette première répétition ou
personne sauf money mais elle entendu
bien puisqu'il faut en parler
lorsque nous étions mariés plan et moi
eh oui monsieur sinclair ne faisait
l'amitié de nous inviter très souvent
ici et de très doux souvenir reste
attaché à cette maison
j'ai beaucoup regretté de ne plus
vouloir maxi oui mais j'écoutais
monnaies il n'était qu'à vous de venir
me rendre visite
rien ne pouvait me faire plus plus et je
sais bien mais j'avais préféré tirer un
trait définitif sur tout ce qui me
rappelait fleuron très bien léger
puisque l'année suivant vous montiez une
pièce de lui oui mais ça c'est ça c'est
le théâtre ça c'est le travail
commissaire il a aussi ses exigences en
revenons à votre sortie vous est donc
allé boire un verre d'eau 15 5 litres
vous avez dû rencontrer eliette dans la
cuisine non je n'ai vu personne
c'est très possible je ne passe tout de
même pas de montant à l'office convient
c'est pourquoi lier pas souvent au jour
derrière la porte
je suis revenu aussitôt après et nous
avons repris la lecture de la pièce que
nous avons interrompu quelques instants
plus tôt pour décider ensemble du choix
d'un acteur pour le rôle qu'ils
restaient à distribuer rôle que mon ami
sinclair avait eu la gentillesse de
tenir en attendant maintenant mieux
mieux parce que ça m'amuse et c'était
une expérience nouvelle pour moi vous
cherchez quelque chose comme ça
ça mais qu'est ce que c'est petit
émetteur miniaturisés qui permet
d'écouter à distance toute notre
conversation quelqu'un écoute tout ce
que l'on dit comme ça je me doutais bien
qu'il ne se contenterait pas de l'image
qu'il leur faudrait aussi le son voyez
que c'est le faux policier qui a placé
ce bidule oui enfin le vrai journaliste
william habib crochet moi j'appelle mon
avocat en fait tu aurais un maître vous
donneriez à toute cette affaire une
publicité supplémentaire ce qui n'est
pas souhaitable car si à sion retraites
il y aura publicité puis ça servira la
pièce a mené vous n'allez pas me dire
que vous avez toujours l'intention de
monter la pièce de plans pourquoi pas
oui nous allons avoir les
avant-premières comme aucun théâtre
n'aura jamais écouté j'ai calculé au
prix de la ligne dans les journaux que
nous avons ce matin plus de 200 millions
de publicités et ça ne fait que
commencer
c'est formidable à un crime comme ça
faisait ça n'arrive pas florence et on
se rendait pas compte à quel point votre
attitude est amoral je m'en fous mon
cher mais si phm lancèrent maxime moi
j'ai signé les contrats
alors croyez vous que la moralité de mes
comédiens ira jusqu à me faire cadeau
d'aidé dit que je leur dois
si je ne dors pas ma signature est bien
vous n'avez qu'à leur demander en tant
que délégué syndical moi je dis
consultons labarthe seulement la base
c'est moi alors d' étrange à mon avis tu
dois évidemment extrait stupide de ne
pas profiter de ces circonstances
exceptionnelles de lancement et puis
enfin j'ai un théâtre sur les bras du
personnel à la mener et puis surtout
j'ai pas d'autres spectacles depuis
pièce aujourd'hui à mardi y'a plus
l'odeur la preuve c'est tout ce que j'ai
trouvé je peux pourtant pas à prouver
qu'on se serve d'un crime pour lancer un
produit de la matrice hasina de bureau
pour promouvoir une pièce sera bien la
première fois qu'il viendra
et grâce à dieu la dernière de il vous
faudra remplacer le ou la coupable ne
l'oublié pas vous allez avoir un autre
cadavre sur les bras un commissaire le
mien si vous m'enlevez ma vedette la
veille de la générale money monique
doucement la douce mao on parle de
vedettes et ils croient tout de suite
qu'il s'agit de lui mais en tout cas il
sera plus facile de trouver un autre
metteur en scène pour faire ton travail
et jouer ton petit rôle qu'un autre
acteur pour me remplacer
ah oui en somme si je comprends bien le
seul qui ne sera plus indispensable à la
représentation c'est vous cher monsieur
pièces afin d'imaginer de même pas que
que je vais me dénoncer pour sauver le
spectacle je connais beaucoup d'auteurs
qui serait capable de bien pires pour ce
faire jouer dites moi cher mettre
l'ambiance avant-hier entre les
protagonistes étaient sorel et détendue
or au très agréable monsieur oui nous
avons sabler le champagne
le champagne mais vous m'aviez cassé sa
bôme et c'est un crime a pas un barbare
le thème je vous présente mes excuses
aux autres oublient autres oublient très
grave
je suis sorti moi aussi pour demander à
eliette de servir le champagne
eliette et y est mais elle n'est jamais
là et liège huy apportez-nous des
rafraîchissements et 10 en pagne banos
ça n'est pas le jour posent sans prague
pendant laquelle vous sortez tous à tour
de rôle les pieds des gens là monsieur
qui savent quoi faire baver comme ça je
suis arrivé justement des libations
l'eau je m'étais même amusé à me faire
passer pour un vrai inspecteurs blog que
je peux de temps en temps c'est pas la
peine est en vente et messieurs sinclair
a failli s'évanouir n'alliez pas la
conscience tranquille supporte mal les
émotions monsieur c'est le privilège de
en somme si je comprends bien vous êtes
le seul policier est arrivé sur les
lieux du crime avant qu'il ne soit
commis oui ou peut-être l'était-il déjà
oui ou peut-être êtes-vous l'assassin
oui dix points que s'est-il passé
ensuite
vous avez repris la lecture après la
pause champagne vous y rester quelques
répliques à dire vous voulez vous avoir
l'amabilité de me le dire nous nous
sommes arrêtés je crois à l'instant où
le personnage que vous interprétez va
chercher le professeur c'est bien ça
il vous voulez me dire les dernières
équipes de l'accès de l'usiné aux i télé
bénévolat
veeva ils sont très bien il existe dans
cette pièce quelque chose de maléfique
je vais chercher le professeur ne nous
laissez pas seuls
est ce que tu crois que c'est bien que
je sois de dos au public comme on répète
pour le commissaire leone au chef
comment est ce que je peux enchaîner
indien suivant je ne serai pas long dit
je veux dire je suis là c'est sa
réplique est ce qu'il dit ça aurait plus
que j'ai à te dire vous oubliez que je
suis là
je suis là vous oubliez que je suis là
nous n'avons rien à craindre tant que
nous resterons tous ensemble surtout si
l'assassin est dans la maison pourquoi
le professeur n'est-il pas des cons le
professeur non non c'est un homme
étrange mais il me fait peur
pourquoi les avez-vous demandé de venir
le professeur mois j'ignorais son
existence jusqu'à ce soir
mais alors pourquoi vient d'annoncer
bien scellier génie pourquoi ça y est
pour écouter la 3 pourquoi je sais
jamais sur lequel font actuellement sur
la mise en culture qu'est ce que tu dis
tu es alors pourquoi
et voilà bonne replay le progrès le
professeur quoi les professeurs je
proteste l'aîné il est mort pour
l'assassinât alors merci rideau fin du
premier acte d'une pièce bouleversante
oui aux as
que s'est il passé entre ce moment est
celui où elle y est t'es venu annoncer
sa macabre découverte
rien il est mort yvan vous voulez dire
que les deux meurtres le vrai et le faux
ont été annoncés presque simultanément
oui c'est ça qui nous a tellement
troublés concert en effet c'est pour le
moins troublant ce que je pourrais lire
votre pièce monsieur bienvenue je serai
d'ailleurs heureux de connaître l'avis
d'un spécialiste
ou alors vous faites beaucoup d'honneur
non mais si la réalité suit de sipa la
fiction le nom du meurtrier de monsieur
bur on doit se trouver entre les lignes
et puis j'ai hâte de savoir ce que vous
avez fait du rôle de l'inspecteur que
désirez-vous voir monsieur au jus de
fruits y a pas autre chose il faut que
je vous remercie monsieur je vous
remercie parce que vous faites garder ma
maison est en ce moment avec ce drame je
suis assailli ça et c'est bien naturel
mais dites-moi chermette je voudrais
vous demander encore une petite
précision pendant que nous y sommes
vous m'avez dit n'avoir reçu aucune
visite c'est de ces derniers temps oui
en effet vous en êtes bien certains
absolument monsieur ma mémoire n'est
plus ce qu'elle était elle est plus ce
qu'elle était mais n'est pas aussi
défaillante que vous entendez l'imaginer
j'ai remarqué que chaque fois que vous
me posez une question vous n'avez pas
l'air convaincu pas ma réponse fuse et
moi mon cher maître mais c'est très
important pour moi mais monsieur ça
l'est peut-être un peu pour moi aussi
pas de coups de téléphone sortant de
l'ordinaire je ne vois pas un merci
monsieur
souvenez-vous ce journaliste suédois qui
voulait à tout prix vous parlais bah oui
ben quoi j'avais oublié tout à fait
normal qu'un journaliste venu
l'interviewer oui ces choses-là
d'habitude ont lieu lors d'un rendez
vous c'est ce que je vais proposer mais
il partait à l'heure même pour la suède
il a téléphoné d'ailleurs dans l'après
midi avoir des renseignements
complémentaires
quel jour et s offrir quelques jours
c'était jeudi jusqu'à preuve du
contraire
ceci pour quel journal travail et il
mais je me suis empressé d'oublier
écoutez moi se souvient d'une chose
c'est qu'il a dit qu'il voulait à tout
prix parler à monsieur avant de rentrer
dans son pays c'est tout voulant croire
que quand elle départ derrière la porte
à des écouteurs
et voyez encore une petite chose qui me
trotte derrière la tête qui me chagrine
pourquoi êtes vous venu répéter ici
tout simplement parce que je désirais
connaître l'opinion de mon ami sinclair
sur ma pièce au delà pourquoi ici à
rambouillet leur ai quand même été plus
simple de vous réunir tous à paris parce
que monsieur sinclair était grippée
grippé bas vous avez été grippé monsieur
non le jardin oui oui un petit peu oui
oui allez votre médicament monsieur
merci et lille non non ne buvait pas
pourquoi dont il ya tellement de
similitudes entre ma pièce est ce que
nous vivons non je l'appris nous voyons
voyons voyons fort mon ami mais vous
dites vous divaguez boyon moi je ne suis
pas superstitieux
et puis d'ailleurs on n'oserait pas
m'ont posé devant la commissaire de
police qui soit commissaire marc tout ça
je vous y autorise mon cher m je ne suis
pas mal
vous vous rendez vous on a fait une
belle peur aux autres j'étais tellement
tard à puce et depuis ces trois jours et
puis vous savez j'ai le coeur très fière
et fragile
jean très fragile et puis cette eau
était glacée il n'en fallait pas
davantage un dieu merci ça n'était pas
grave
non j'aurais voulu voir la tête du
commissaire quand j'ai eu un
étourdissement lui qui m'avait conseillé
war il n'en menait pas large
haha vous croyez qu'il se doutent je
suis sûr qu'ils c'est possible faire
tout cas s'ils ne le sait pas encore il
la prendra vite
c'est un homme méticuleux opiniâtre
intelligent c'est peut-être par
délicatesse qui n'a pas fait allusion à
cet entrefilet paru dans la presse mais
qui voudront en savoir davantage et dans
ces cas là les sources d'information ne
manquent pas il aura 40 visite à mes
confrères lui dira sans aucune manif
d'ailleurs la considération qu'on
semblait manifesté à l'égard de bureau
et voudra à rien ça crie oui justement
avez-vous draps savoir le forez chaud
c'est bien ça qui m'inquiète
je n'avais pas le choix mais je vous en
pensez mais ti
ça me fait plaisir de parler à quelqu'un
et de me confier à un ami
vous êtes le seul au courant depuis
trois jours je ne vis plus comment tous
avait il commencé lorsque duru pour mon
prédécesseur est mort et que j'ai été
nommé secrétaire perpétuel buron a fait
irruption chez moi pour me dire qu'ils
briguent le fauteuil de la coi mais ce
qu'il s'est montré agressif il m'a dit
qu'il était capable de faire des
révélations croustillantes
il comptait sur vos nouvelles fonctions
ben pour obtenir un nombre suffisant de
bois il avait fait exprès un voyage là
bas sur les lieux de marc petit frasques
de jeunesse pour recueillir certains
témoignages qu'il aurait agrémenté de
détails plus ou moins exacts vous voyez
d'ici le scandale de goyer qui l'aurait
mis ses menaces à exécution
j'en suis certaine c'était entre
je suis très fatigué et laurent je vous
accompagne à nouveau posée alors oui
vous ne savez pas franc je voudrais
m'endormir et ne pas me réveiller par
mon jeu ramé ne dis pas de bêtises
georges
bonjour mademoiselle je peux vous aider
vous cherchez quelque chose au nom d'un
pourquoi pas pour rien ses mots quand je
vois quelqu'un à quatre pattes
bousculant tous les coussins d'un canapé
je m'imagine toujours qu'il cherche
quelque chose ça doit être de la
déformation professionnelle à la vérité
je cherchais mon briquet que je croyais
avoir laissé orange voulez vous une
cigarette avec les y en ait plus alors
sans indiscrétion pourquoi cherchiez
vous votre briquet à mais rien je
croyais avoir laissé tomber si tout
excuser moi je vous taquine et je suis
content de me trouver seul ici avec vous
je voulais vous montrer ce si cette
photo de vous
vous l'avez vous trouvé on suit celui à
qui vous l'avez si gentiment dédicacé
c'est une très jolie photo vous êtes
plus jolie au naturel
merci commissaire fiche la reprendre
bien entendu mais auparavant je voulais
vous poser toute question
voilà l'autre jour quand je vous ai
demandé si vous connaissiez monsieur
buron vous m'avez répondu je le
connaissais comme ça pour moi connaître
quelqu'un comme ça c'est ne connaître ni
plus ni moins qu'un autre est ce que je
me trompe
or d'après dédicace de cette photo vous
sembliez prouver pour lui des sentiments
très éloignées l'indifférence
je ne vois pas en quoi des relations
avec monsieur bureau peuvent vous
intéresser commissaire c'est à moi d'en
juger
figurez vous que nous sommes
impardonnable dans la police mais quand
quelqu'un a été assassiné tout ce qui le
touche de près ou de loin et surtout de
prêts nous intéresse sans doute vous
avez raison je ne suis stupide d'excusés
voir ce que vous étiez au courant de la
visite qu'il devait rendre à monsieur
sinclair c'est lui qui vous en avez fait
pas en effet ne m'en avait parlé vous
avait-il dit que le rendez vous avait
été avancée de deux heures non vous avez
dû être surprise de voir arriver si tôt
je vous remercie dites moi où se trouve
la salle de bain la salle de bains
l'asse ça dans le couloir la deuxième ou
troisième pour ta bouche à drac pardon
non c'est à droite ou à gauche à droite
je crois je vous remercie
nous avons de la visite c'est notre cd
votre ami julien venez venez venez venez
venez charmant leers
vous ne me répondez pas mais je suis sûr
que vous êtes de mon avis d'élégants
sympathique former un très joli couple
mes félicitations bonjour commissaire un
bonjour comment allez vous bien
commissaire merci qu'est ce que vous
faisiez dans le pack vous cherchez
quelque chose mais pas du tout pourquoi
non mais ne t'inquiète pas c'est une
manie le commissaire nous imagine tous
occupés à chercher quelque chose
je comprends pas mottaki
si quelqu'un cherche ici c'est bien moi
alors commissaire comment marche cette
enquête trottine si vous nous avez tous
convoqués cet après midi c'est bien pour
quelque chose ça je l'espère bien vous
savez je continue de penser la solution
du problème se trouve ici dans cette
maison et je compte sur vous pour me et
des mois et alors vous particulièrement
je veux dire que je compte sur vous tous
pour m'aider à découvrir la vérité tout
cas commissaire si je peut vous être
utile je suis à votre entière
disposition
merci ça c'est très aimable de votre
part vous êtes venu tout seul cet après
midi ah non non guillon m'accompagne en
voiture d'ailleurs il est allé la gare
et à oui je l'avais je l'avais remarqué
je veux parler de sa voiture du temps
elle est superbe c'est cela c'est une
porte une voix une par une porsche
france parie que ça coûte les yeux de la
tête
pari gagné bah c'est pas pour nous
parler d'abord de guillaume que vous
nous avez fait venir ma pourquoi pas en
voyez vous quand le métier tour de la
routine
je pense qu'il est bon de faire
diversion de temps en temps puis de
parler d'autre chose ça ne nous
ressemble pas commissaire où on se croit
au contraire que toutes vos questions
même les plus anodines ont une
signification bien précise ainsi genou
ne pense pas vous soyez rester chez moi
à 20 minutes ce matin uniquement pour
l'agrément de la conversation
mais pourquoi pas je serais bien resté
plus longtemps mais j'avais d'autres
visites avant je suis resté que vingt
minutes
oui commissaire vous êtes arrivé à 22h40
vous êtes reparti à 11 heures précises
je m'en souviens très bien c'était juste
au moment où la pente d'une semaine est
joseph autres dérangeait pas du concert
j'étais radio parler de notre métier
à moi aussi un métier qui me passionne
c'est moi aussi il m'arrive de jouer la
comédie
haha ça va évidemment ce jeudi mon
propre texte
j'improvise en quelque sorte je me suis
toujours demandé comment vous faites
pour apprendre tous ces rôles que vous
interprétez qu'est ce que vous faisiez
avant d'être comédien j'étais monteur à
la télévision intéressant ce serait
intéressant sur asos qu'ils avaient
inscrit entre entrées je ne suis pas en
retard a pas du tout bonjour commissaire
même bonjour on l'appelle revanche mon
lapin ou shu
je ne fais pas attention commissaire au
théâtre nous aimons nous donner des
petits mots tendres j'avais déjà
remarqué je commence à m'y faire
c'est pour l'habitude dans la police
j'ai rien contre a je vais vous demander
de me laisser seuls quelques instants
avec monsieur bazin ce qui est bien
c'est parfait on va répéter la scène du
2 tu veux alors oui tiens tu veux
inscrire
je suis content de vous voir
dites moi j'ai trouvé qu'est-ce que j'en
ai oui j'ai trouvé sur la machine à
écrire de monsieur buron cette feuille
de papier certainement sa dernière
critique n'a pris le temps de la finir
ce moment il ya quelques lignes vous
concernant quels que soient les risques
que l'on court il faut dire la vérité
parler pour une fois du travail de
guillaume baczynski quels que soient les
risques que l'on court qu'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire par là il aurait fallu le lui
demander mais enfin c'est à vous que je
le demande
pensez vous vraiment commissaire que
j'aurais pu menacer bureau je me pose la
question si vous voulez mon avis je le
sollicite
c'est bien étrange ma dernière mise en
scène remonte à six mois de quoi parlent
et ils d'eau que dit le début de
l'article
je me suis posé la même question à mon
avis ce doit être une sorte de panorama
sur la dernière saison théâtrale c'est
destiné à une revue en tout cas ce que
vous venez de me dire est une phrase
toute faite
c'est un aphorisme qui signifie que
toute vérité n'est pas toujours bonne à
dire est qu'il est quelquefois dangereux
d'écrire ce que l'on pense
pourquoi faut mentir alors le mensonge
est une nécessité élémentaires de la vie
en commun voilà un bel à faurisson
quoi qu'il en soit bureau ne vous portez
pas dans son coeur lui demandez pas de
mai mais il aura propos oui puisque nous
parlons de deux mensonges mahé menti
avant-hier
quand vous m'avez dit quelqu'un de la
mairie du vésinet vous avez téléphoné
ici nous avons vérifié personnes de la
mairie nous a appelés ont intrigué par
votre attitude j'ai demandé à mes
services de prendre quelques
renseignements sur vous non rassurez
vous une enquête rapide et discrète
je ne savais pas que la discrétion était
la qualité des menteurs de la police
j'ai pas dit ça
nous faisons ce que nous pouvons nous
avons découvert que vous aviez eu dans
le passé des fréquentations douteuses
que voulez vous dire ce que je dis
douteuse pas dans le sens d'un probable
ou d'hypothétiques nous avons
soigneusement vérifiés des
fréquentations dans la qualité est mise
en cause
c'est de l'histoire ancienne commissaire
vous avez de gros soucis d'argent
ah ça c'est plus récent vous vivez très
au dessus de vos moyens j'en connais
plus vous dessous de toute façon je ne
vois pas le rapport entre les soucis
d'argent et le meurtre du bureau ben il
existe peut-être ce rapport dans le coup
de fil de ce mystérieux correspondants
dont vous allez bien sûr me livrer
maintenant la véritable identité
et bien voilà commissaire un bonjour mon
canard un lapin
ce commissaire le maître vous attend
nous reprend cette conversation plus
tard
comment va le mettre beaucoup mieux mais
toute la publicité donnée à cette
affaire le meilleur de lui un excellent
pour vous ça il espérait enfin de côté
tout de même pas qu'on va assassiner un
critique dramatique à ce qu'une de vos
créations
hélas dello sport qui est pour moi un
très bon elle n'allait pas conclure que
je souhaite personnellement la mort d'un
critique
ben oui a dit don à propos j'ai lu votre
pièce a alors elle est pas terminé
pourquoi
eh bien j'ai hésité assez longuement
entre deux dénouements possibles
et puis je ne souhaitais pas ou tout au
moins le plus tard possible donner à mes
interprètes la clé de l'énigme de pour
qui l'horizon mais d'abord parce que
j'étais curieux de voir leurs réactions
et puis je pensais qu ainsi il répèterai
peut-être avec un peu plus de sincérité
bonjour mon poulet pardon on part d'un
commissaire annoncé par ex
nous parlions avec monsieur de sa pièce
il ya une chose qui m'a frappé j'aurais
aimé avoir votre opinion là-dessus
laquelle nous avons tous été
impressionnés par le parallélisme entre
ce qui s'est passé ici votre histoire
des coïncidences avait fait oui c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
ne parlons même pas des deux meurtres le
vrai il faut qu'ils sont étroitement
mêlées mais enfin après la lecture j'ai
trouvé que ces coïncidences aller
beaucoup plus loin on pourrait presque
identifier chacun de vos personnages à
chacun d'entre vous effectivement oui
nous aimons ce que oui je n'y avais pas
pensé et moi j'y ai pensé c'est très
très très troublant dites moi en dehors
de de vous ici là qui qui d'autre avait
lu la pièce ont peu de gens vous savez
j'ai quelques acteurs qui avait été
pressenti pour les rôles qui restent à
distribuer comment peu de gens oui et
tout ce qu'ils ont refusé une ribambelle
d'amis l'armée producteurs mais je
serais incapable de vous donner la liste
complète comme c'est ce ne sera pas
nécessaire madame c'est ici que je dois
chercher continuer à penser que
l'assassin est parmi nous le tueur dans
la maison non ne voulait surtout pas
prévoir qu'est ce qui se passe pour moi
il connaissait la c'est ça et on a
supprimé pour qu'ils se tapent des
changements brille c'est lui l'assassin
s'est suicidé voilà je te rappelle que
maxime cinquième est un vieil ami et en
a des similitudes avec ma pièce il lui
arrivait quelque chose je ne pardonnerai
pas enflant m'ont dit pas ce qui s'est
passé derrière derrière lemaitre va très
bien la même retrouvé toute sa vitalité
figurez-vous qu'il a surpris un
journaliste perché sur un arbre qui
domine la fenêtre de sa chambre il a
tiré dessus avec cette carabine de
gosses qui ferait pas de mal à un lapin
ali a travaillé
ranger sa et ne laisser aucune arme à
portée de sa main je remonte le voir
soyez très aimable de m'attendre tout
sicile un moment vous voyez mes enfants
fallait pas en faire un drame
non mais c'est vrai un meurtre passe
mais deux là c'est trop donc je t'admire
julien d'avoir l'esprit à plaisanter et
surtout maintenant si tu semble un peu
trop négligé que le commissaire est
persuadé que l'assassin se trouve parmi
vous parmi nous tous soient inclus non
parce que moi ya une chose dont je suis
certain c'est que l'assassin ce n'est
pas moi ni moi ni moi non plus alors
c'est toi
ne sois pas idiot parfait alors par
déduction c'est moi voilà c'est une
affaire réglée c'est moi ou lambert info
que défile pas là oui pourquoi il a
certainement été convoqué comme nous
tous
bien sûr c'est lambert il nous a dit
qu'il en avait marre de jouer les rôles
de flic est bas il a voulu changer
d'emploi n'avait pas remarqué la tête
qu'il faisait l'autre jour quand il est
arrivé la tête d'un type là qu'il était
un mauvais coup tu es drôle hein ça ne
te bats pas tu es vraiment pas un acteur
de composition
non tu es un grand premier rôle tu nous
l'a assez répété tu n'es pas un comique
ne quitte pas ton emploi
toi tu n'as pas quitter ton emploi c'est
ton emploi qui t'a quitté haut que ses
gentils que c'est drôle est que ces
nouveaux n'empêche que je te préfère
dans le texte des autres ah oui oui même
dans celui de florent on sait que le tue
le plus grand acteur de ta génération
que les américains ne peuvent plus faire
un film sans faire appel à toi tu nous a
déjà dit tout ça je viens on sait que tu
va tourner le premier rôle dans le film
de zakia et que tu vas gagner des galons
de vedette de cinéma c'est le curieux
tout le lait pas rappeler encore une
fois
en tout cas il peut nous quitter à la
100e ça c'est dans son contrat
enfin si toutefois nous allons jusqu'à
la santé toujours le mot pour rire moyen
de qui me fait rigoler c'est que julien
va jouer du texte de buron plein avais
tu savais pas zakia a confié les
dialogues de son film à bureaux l'action
doit se dérouler dans la périphérie on
sait rien pourquoi dans la périphérie
il vas tu te rappelles pas à de ces
derniers papiers buron avait baptisé
alain delon de banlieue irrésistible à
regarde pas cette loi molle a de toute
façon ce pauvre environ n'avaient
certainement pas commencé à écrire ses
dialogues
dix mois florent tu devrais les maîtres
tape peau la pointe bic à la disposition
des producteurs maintenant ça devient
excellente idée comme ça on m'accusera
d'avoir trucider bureau pour lui piquer
ses dialogues
en tout cas les biron il n'avait pas
besoin d'attendre la mort des autres
pour qu'on lui confie des dialogues de
films
nous ne serons jamais assez
reconnaissant d'avoir accepté de jouer
cette oeuvre est avec les ringards que
nous sommes ça va ça va ça va croyez-moi
va falloir battre vachement défendra
cette pièce pourquoi tu vas l'attaqué en
train de rôle
écoutez moi je vais vous dire une chose
attention parce que julien va me dire
une chose
l'idée que génique monia us et de
confier le rôle principal mais parce que
moi j'ai mon idée sur la pièce i'm all
là n'est ce pas alors ton idée sur
laquelle je m'en fous la seule chose que
je demande c'est de suivre mes
indications
écoute moi bien monsieur le metteur en
scène je jouerai avec ma personnalité
hors arrêt piste emmerde hannah si vous
commencez à parler à mon goût vers là
moi je m'en vais
tu sais bien que tu ne peux pas le
commissaire nous a demandé de l'attendre
écoute moi bien j'ai quand même deux
choses à te dire concernant les
indications ne va pas faire plaisir au
théâtre alors qu'il est dans le bureau
s'il te plaît pas ce que vous oubliez un
peu trop souvent que nous sommes ici
chez le secrétaire perpétuel de
l'académie française et je ne voudrais
pas que quand mon ami sinclair va
redescendre
il vous trouve ici en rade vous colle t
il arrive au palais pour une fois écouté
la voix de la sagesse les coutures
n'allait pas il est en pleine forme on
va descendre dans un instant
mademoiselle je crois avoir mis la main
sur ce que vous cherchiez tout à l'heure
mon briquet non votre poudrier bien à
vous n'est ce pas oui je comprends
pourquoi vous le rechercher avec tant
d'acharnement dents en or en ravissant
pendez le savez vous nous l'avons
découvert dans la selle de base sans
doute non dans la pièce à côté où
attendaient la victime juste sur la
console à côté de laquelle il était
assis monsieur sinclair qui vient de me
remettre
je ne comprends pas bon moi qui comptais
sur vous sur moi pourquoi est pour me
permettre de faire un grand pas dans mon
enquête
vous êtes la dernière personne à avoir
vu monsieur buron vivant ou la première
à l'avoir trouvé mort
j'espérais que vous aviez me dire dans
quel état vous l'aviez découvert je ne
comprends rien vaut ces assignations
comme serre je n'ai jamais vu monsieur
buron ici alors il faudra me dire ce que
faisait votre poudrier sur la console à
côté de la victime il ya des initiales à
l'intérieur du boîtier fvl pour non plus
et qu'ils appartiennent ne cherchez pas
comme ils serrent ce sont les initiales
de mon ex mari un cadeau pour une
interprète à qui il avait trouvé tous
les talents je vous demande pardon je
savais pas je n'en crois rien
toute façon je vois pas exactement le
rapport qui peut exister entre des
initiales sur un poudrier refaire il ya
plus de cinq ans une jeune comédienne et
le meur de la critique dramatique ce qui
est admirable ici c'est que personne ne
voit le rapport entre ce qui le concerne
et la sauce il faut pourtant bien bien
née oui je crois surtout que vous
essayez de créer la zizanie entre nous
et vous avez tort commissaire nous avons
les uns pour les autres qui estime une
affection
c'est vrai nous formons une grande
famille ça je sais j'avais déjà remarqué
enfin n'oubliez tout de même pas qu'il y
à un assassin dans votre grande famille
ça c'est vous qui le dites encore
faut-il le prouver
à force de chercher je finirai bien par
tomber bonjour tout le monde
cinéma1 sous-commissaire ge sont si vite
que j'ai pu savant j'arrive du sud au
début de show mots avec rôle vous êtes
en train de tourner l'avant un
contractuel à la porte d'une école moi
monsieur lambert je voudrais vous
demander quelques petites précisions à
votre disposition c'est comme ça mais
affirmer que la dernière fois peut être
vu ici vous avez vu quelqu'un sur la
terrasse en arrivant c'est exact en
l'espace d'une seconde 1 ou femme
impossible à préciser
voyez d'indiquer l'endroit exact à très
volontiers par faut s'arrêter à hauteur
de cette fenêtre dans quel sens se
déplacer cet inconnu sur la terrasse oui
et bien de là à aux parcomètres à la je
pense là comme ça willow on finirait par
faire la circulation
et personne ne pouvait le voir d'ici
puisqu'il est peut-être en bas des
marches donc en contrebas on aurait dit
une ombre rasant bible avant de pénétrer
dans cette pièce qu'avez vous remarqué
réfléchissez bien avait d'abord j'ai
aperçu des silhouettes de mes camarades
dans cette pièce
et puis de l'autre côté j'ai vu un homme
assis dans le petit salon là et qui
disait le monde
vous étiez alors une vingtaine de mètres
de la terrasse environ monsieur buron a
été tué d'une balle dans la nuque à bout
portant fallait que vous soyez très près
de lui pour voir qu'il lisait le monde
je n'ai su qu'après quand on a découvert
durant le journal était plié sur la
console à côté lui quand vous êtes
approché veut voir connu monsieur buron
non non il avait le dos tourné il tenait
le journal grand ouvert devant lui voilà
un journal venu veuillez me montrer dans
quelle position il se trouvait à peu
près comme ceci d'après ce que je sais
monsieur lambert monsieur buron a été
assassiné quelques instants après votre
arrivée dans cette maison c'est comme
cervelle je veux même pas imaginer
eliette est allés lui porter un
rafraîchissement quelques instants après
vous faisiez votre apparition dans
l'horreur eliette vous a introduit dans
ce salon
en arrivant dans cette pièce how
remarqué qu'il manquait quelqu'un mois
comme c'est d'ailleurs je voulais déjà
dit j'étais allé dans la salle de bain
pour leur maquiller oui c'est exact
d'ailleurs je lui avais fait remarquer
que son rouge à lèvres avait débordé
elle avait dû se remaquiller trop vite
tu t'en souviens car les noms je me
souviens pas peut-être voulait-elle
cacher l'émotion et l'émotion mais
quelle émotion
on s'y reconnaît que voulez-vous avoir
l'amabilité d'emmener quelques instants
mademoiselle dans la pièce à côté je
veux rester seul avec votre hauteur et
votre directrice
bien sûr vous observez vous savez
commissaire quand une femme veut cacher
quelque chose surtout une comédienne
j'aimerais bien que vous me parliez de
votre soeur
mais comment de ma soeur croyez vous
qu'il soit vraiment utile de raviver des
souvenirs aussi pénible je n'ai rien à
vous dire que vous le sachiez déjà votre
soeur était la femme de monsieur buron
elle s'est suicidée et vous avez rendu
buron responsable de sa mère dans une
certaine mesure il était vous avez même
dit jaurès à pau oui je les dis et je le
redis aujourd'hui
j'aurais voulu de supprimer moi même
peut-être l'avez-vous faire on commença
par personne interposée
vous êtes fous on se fait beaucoup on
lit ça tous les jours on la presse
suivant un ski quelqu'un qui engage un
professionnel pour exécuter les basses
besognes
il fréquente pas de tueur commissaire et
je n'ai pas les moyens d'offrir leurs
services
oui c'est vrai vous m'avez dit que votre
trésorerie n'était guère florissante
pourtant vous avez fait une avance de 50
mille francs à monsieur sur sa mise en
scène quel rapport tous les metteurs en
scène touche une avance sur leurs droits
me suis renseigné jamais aucun metteur
en scène sur la place de paris n'a
touché une telle somme
pourquoi en quoi cela vous concerne
l'éthique ou voulez vous en venir à ce
si vous avez eu des fréquentations
douteuses dans le passé vous l'avez
reconnu vous avez de gros soucis
d'argent vous l'avez reconnu aussi vous
êtes très lié à votre directrice que
vous adorez vous auriez très bien pu
trouver dans vos anciennes relations
quelqu'un qui moyennant finance
débarrasse madame de celui qu'elle
tenait pour responsable de la mort de sa
soeur mais vous êtes fous je vais user
de mes relations pour convertir
immédiatement cette enquête
j'ai pas dit que vous l'avez fait
j'envisage toutes les hypothèses avoué
pour ranger votre soeur sud de tan tan
voilà ses commissaires j'en ai assez de
toutes vos insinuations
j'étouffe moi ici j'ai besoin d'air pur
si vous permettez mais c'est le
commissaire vous demande au téléphone
monsieur guillaume tu t'en fait pas toi
cinquante mille francs d'avancé sur ta
mise en scène money des données
à moi elle m'a refusé 20 mille francs
d'avoirs sur mes droits que veux-tu les
femmes mais qu'est ce que ça serait si
tu les aimait aussi aie aie aie
bon avec moi 1 mais pourquoi parce qu'il
ya en ce moment money est bouleversée
alors je crois que c'est peut-être le
moment de tenter de toute façon si elle
ne me donne pas mes vingt mille francs à
toi tu me donneras la moitié des 50 à
l'honneur mais tu plaisantes là dans ces
cas là jamais alors de noé plan ne
prouve pas les couleurs nationales des
sables monsieur le commissaire oui mais
pourquoi vous n'avez pas hétéro chez moi
qu'est ce que je veux c'est fait
mais rien du tout mademoiselle je vous
ai demandé si vous aviez vu ou entendu
quelque chose vous m'avez répondu que
non et ça vous syfy écouter et tout le
monde ici avait au moins une bonne
raison de supprimer monsieur buron vous
vous ne le connaissiez même pas mais si
monsieur il était déjà venu plus de faim
ici rendre visite à metz et saint clair
et je dois dire que je ne trouvais
vraiment pas sympathique et se croient
bien que monsieur ça clair non plus
d'ailleurs même qu'une fois s'est
entendus se disputer
allons bon enfin c'est tout de même pas
une raison suffisante pour que vous ayez
eu envie de le supprimer
qu'en savez vous et puis si vous aviez
une quelque chose à me dire vous me
voyez des mais moi je voulais traiter
rocher comme tout le monde
si vous m'avez fait asseoir dans votre
bureau un projecteur dans les yeux entre
deux inspecteurs en bras de chemise
mangeant des sandwichs et buvant de la
bière et peut-être que j'aurai fini par
avouer mademoiselle de ne sommes pas au
cinéma celui qu auriez vous avouer que
j'ai vu la salle qu'est ce que vous
dites là oui mais c'est le commissaire
je les vis non si vous le connaissez
oui alors dites moi maintenant ce que
vous savez enfin et bien
eh bien eh bien voilà je suis allé
demander à monsieur buron s'ils
voulaient par quelque chose
il m'a dit oui à ce moment là il était
vivant quand je suis revenu dû porter à
vers le des morts alors lisez le journal
il m'a dit merci sur tourne à la cuisine
à ce moment là on a sonné c'était un
comédien
vous savez celui qui paie le commissaire
dans la pierre à je les conduis si
rejoindre les autres et quand je suis
repassé près du petit salon
j'ai entendu du bruit ça m'a surprise
j'ai écouté et j'ai reconnu la voix de
monsieur buron il parlait dont il
n'était pas mort et donc il n'était pas
tout seul
c'est alors que j'ai vu la jeune actrice
sortir caroline jeu surtout dans la
cuisine sur chaque plateau pour
débarrasser les verts et quand je suis
revenu dans le petit salon de monsieur
biron était mort il y avait sur la
console près de la côte est du journal
le poudrier de la demoiselle
je les ramasse et j'ai donné mais c'est
saint clair voilà les toucher à rien
d'autre on pariait monsieur le
commissaire et le journal que lisait
monsieur bur ont été soigneusement pliés
comme je les trouvais ah oui exactement
je vous remercie votre modèle eliette
merci eliette mais de faire faire un
grand pas mon enquête
vous auriez pu savoir tout ça avant si
vous m'aviez dit roger plutôt
commissaire alors vous allez l'arrêté
commissaires n'ont pas tout de suite de
ça il faut d'abord que je vérifie
quelques petits détails à bord et
surtout pas un mot à quiconque de ce que
vous venez de me raconter à danser oui
oui vous la gentillesse de porter un
verre d'eau à madame bâ dit moi j'ai une
bonne nouvelle pour vous le revolver de
monsieur sinclair n'est pas l'armé du
crime
c'est le rassure qu'à moitié
comment va votre directrice mieux mais
je vous l'avais dit il ya certains
sujets que vous auriez mieux fait de ne
pas aborder avec elle oui ça j'en suis
désolé et j'espère qu'elle ne m'en
tiendra pas rigueur
d'autant que je suis absolument
convaincu que bureau on était absolument
pour rien dans le suicide de sa soeur
elle était nous reste et nikci elle le
tient toujours pour responsable ça ne
change rien poil on rejoue rappelle tout
de même que cette malheureuse histoire
remonte à plus de vingt ans et on se
demande vraiment pourquoi maudire est
attendu aussi longtemps pour se venger
de lyon il ya une petite chose c'est
vous qui me tracasse là
c'est votre attitude l'autre jour quand
m sinclair s'est apprêté à boire avoué
qu'elle était pour le moins étrange non
j'ai pensé à ma pièce aux coïncidences
du début c'est vrai alors j'ai été
moi-même surpris je dois dire de de
cette réaction spontanée que juin ainsi
comme dans votre pièce l'assassin est le
meilleur ami du professeur vous est tout
désigné pour être notre suspect numéro
un laisser leur chance aux autres
d'autant que vous voyez ici au bureau
vous croyez que j'aurais été assez bête
pour faire moi même dans la vie ce que
je fais faire à mon assassin dans ma
pièce et vous dites ça parce que vous
connaissez la fin de votre pièce mais
moi je la connais pas alors maintenant
que je vous ai fait remarquer cette
similitude vous avez pu très bien ont
changé le dénouement
c'est peut-être même pour ça que vous
nous le cacher cette fin je ne serai pas
bourgeois pas bon pas mac os nous sommes
entre nous
oui bien me le dire vous avez bien une
petite idée de la fin
oui
à
et vous monsieur le commissaire moi
aussi vous permettez je vais prendre des
nouvelles de ma directrice
je vous en prie j'espère que je ne vous
dérange pas monsieur mais non pas du
tout excuser moi mon cher mais vous êtes
ici chez vous je vous remets toi et vous
bien sûr que je les manquer tout à fait
certain c'est dommage pourtant j'avais
j'ai vu des règles et en même temps
qu'il ne faut pour le dire
il a eu peur si je l'avais tuée j'aurais
inculpé d'homicide involontaire en
d'homicide par imprudence mais enfin
j'ai tout de même demandé à l est de ne
laisser aucune arme à portée de votre
main dites moi mon ami est ce que vous
prenez pour agathe heures je sais très
bien ne pouvez pas tuer un lapin avec
cette âme c'est un jouet calme et neveu
a oublié chi colonel d'artillerie
monsieur alors je vous en prie ne
parlait pas de moi comme d'un gosse
auprès duquel il faut pas laisser
traîner une boîte d'allumettes de peur
qu'ils affichent faire à la maison
pardonnez-moi m ce n'est pas voulu vous
blesser je voudrais vous demander encore
une petite précision laquelle oui vous
m'avez dit que vous n'aviez jamais
téléphoné à monsieur buron pour changer
l'heure de votre rendez vous
ça c'est tout à fait exact on est bien
certain pk6 nu et vous l'ont pardonnez
moi mais je voulais vous demander sans
vous offenser
si vous le niez s'il ne vous arrive pas
de temps à autres d'avoir des trous de
mémoire vous dépassez la mesure mon ami
pensez vous vraiment que je sois dans un
état de sénilité aussi avant en fait il
peut arriver qu'on oublie certains
événements et que de toute bonne foi on
affirme des contrevérités va et vous qui
êtes l'auteur d'un célèbre ouvrage sur
l'irrationnel est mieux placé que le
commun des mortels pour savoir qu'il
existe des événements tout à fait
inexplicable
il y à il y a des choses
tout à fait invraisemblable par exemple
l'interview de ce fameux journaliste
suédois mais nous avons soigneusement
vérifiés auprès de toutes les agences de
presse nous n'avons trouvé trace nulle
part mais dit que je les ai inventées
gratteux mythomane et amnésique vous me
comblez monsieur enfin une présence
agréable
merci cher maître poudrier je croyais
l'avoir perdu j'avais simplement oublié
dites-moi vanoise haine pour une
comédienne
vous n'avez pas beaucoup de mémoire que
voulez-vous dire commissaire votre
coudrier la porte de la salle de bain
c'est bien la deuxième à gauche mais
mais au premier étage voulez vous
mademoiselle avoir la gentillesse de
demander à tous vos camarades de revenir
ici je vous prie messieurs je n'arrive
pas à imaginer que je meurtrier le
bureau soit parmi eux
je suis certain qu'il est ici êtes vous
bien sûr de ne pas vous tromper
ça pourrait vous coûter cher commissaire
allait nous faire attendre encore loupé
à manger des rendez vous au théâtre
inquiète pas monsieur le commissaire
connaît maintenant le nom de l'assassin
quoi d'exact cette fois ci il ne se
contentera pas des comparaisons
éventuels avec ma pièce ans
j'ai des preuves alors faites nous en
profiter nous sommes impatients de
connaître l'assassin qui se cachent
parmi nous monsieur lambert
l'autre jour quand vous êtes arrivé ici
vous m'avez affirmé avoir vu monsieur
bur en lisant son journal grand ouvert
devant lui
oui ellle est là en effet trouvé dans
cette position en lui apportant un verre
oui quelques instants après la
découverte du meurtre on a retrouvé le
journal soigneusement pliées à côté de
lui
oui si vous l'aviez tué n'auriez propres
et le temps me replier son journal
oui alors là non alors que mademoiselle
est entré quelques instants après non et
c'est alors que monsieur bur on a
soigneusement replier son journal pour
bavarder avec quelques minutes
non c'est ou alors il faudra me dire par
quel voix mystérieuse votre courrier est
arrivé sur la console à côté de la vie
tu ne finis pas moi l'assassin a lu la
pièce
c'est ce qui lui a donné l'idée de la
mise en scène du meurtre
il savait que monsieur buron de venir
ici à 5 heures mais il fallait qu'il
soit là avant pendant la répétition et
c'est pourquoi il fallait que m sinclair
avance l'heure du rendez vous ce qu'il a
fait non je vous faire entendre quelque
chose
c'est le message que nous avons relevés
sur le répondeur automatique de monsieur
bur ont coûté bien cher monsieur chez
maxim's à la clé un petit contre temps
m'oblige à décaler notre rendez vous
jeudi pourrait vous mener à 3 heures je
ne sais si vous êtes d'accord une équipe
de téléphonie et dans le cas contraire
je n'y comprends rien c'est diaboliks il
a peut-être raison ce commissaire je
suis de nos gars je suis devenu gâteux
ou peut être un simple dédoublement de
la personnalité
que voulez-vous dire commissaire m
sinclair c'est mieux que moi de quoi je
veux parler
imaginez qu'il était victime d'un
chantage jeta quels propos de la part de
buron pour entrer à l'académie française
après semblables n'ont laissé laisser
mon ami je vois quoi le comm ca fait
d'allusion il se réfère à mon ouvrage
windows ou où je défends la théorie du
dédoublement de la personnalité ou je
soutient la thèse suivante un individu
peut à son insu commettre des actes
répréhensibles
c'est bien cela n'est ce pas tant peu
près ce qui peut être mon cas eh bien
monsieur avant de me passer les menottes
passez-moi dans la fin du message la fin
la dernière phrase est dans le cadre
très bien vous méditant manier vous au
risque de vous décevoir je suis pas
encore tout à fait gratuit ni victime
devait être propre théorie je voulais
vous dire je veux dit
monsieur que jamais je n'aurais prononcé
cette phrase
veuillez m'appeler d'ici jeudi ce qui
était une faute de français est
impardonnable de la part d'un
académicien mais veuillez m'appeler
d'ici à jeudi
et oui moi j'aurais dit d'ici jeudi mais
enfin ça ne m'étonne pas sa tâche
s'annonce intéressant ça ce qui voudrait
dire que ce message n'est ma n'est pas
de vous c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
comprendre aux rassurez vous je savais
que ce mais que vous n'étiez pas
l'auteur de ce message
mais alors c'est pourquoi me tourmenter
ainsi oui pourquoi nous torturer vous
tous les uns après les autres
inutilement
qui vous a dit que c'était inutile je
suis désolé madame mais ça fait partie
de mon travail joli travail en vérité et
qu'elle rapidement cessé de jouer avec
nous au chat et à la souris puisque vous
savez qui est le coupable
arrêté le mais arrêter le jeu vous
préviens commissaire je vous préviens
moi je suis à bout de nerfs de ses mots
ni aller se reposer vous savez très bien
quelle est pour rien cette histoire il
m'a bouleversé tout allait en évoquant
la mort de ma soeur mais je lui ai dit
qu'elle était le racheter il dit tout de
suite qu'elle était faudra avait-elle
été soigné bien sûr mais j'ai toujours
tenu buron pour responsable de sa mort
est jugé très bien qu'il avait été
profondément affecté infecte tous les
atouts ne pas nous dire que c'est à
cause de ça venait de niort avait de
toute façon j'ai dit également
commissaire pourquoi mon ami
auraient-elles attendu vingt ans pour se
venger de dire oh oui pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas en effet je n'ai rien
oublié mois
je vais vous dire quelque chose ce
dessert avant-hier quand buron était là
c'était précisément le jour anniversaire
de la mort de ma soeur ça va nous coûter
puisque vous savez tout à l'heure
finissant permettrait quand même de
mener mon enquête comme bon me semble
finir 34 commissaire c'est moi qui étais
bureau cacher tu racontes j'allais pas
possible pourquoi pas possible
d'expliquer nous sommes je n'ai rien à
vous dire puisque vous savez la vérité
le mobile danger ma soeur bien sûr mais
aussi tous les comédiens qu'il a si
injustement attaquée depuis plus de
vingt ans pour me tue folle mais elle
est complètement folle ne l'écouté pas
monsieur le commissaire elle divague
toi aussi tu crois que je suis folle non
je ne suis pas folle je suis simplement
très particulièrement sensibles comme
tous les comédiens mais ça tu ne l'as
jamais compris ni comme marine et comme
auteur même héros lâcher c'est tout
c'est là dessus que vous comptiez les
spas commissaire
eh bien vous avez gagné on n'est pas
chez les monnaies dites moi ce n'est pas
vrai si maxime c'est la vérité je ne
pouvais plus mais vous maxime où je suis
sûr que vous allez me comprendre la
sensibilité c'est la plus grande qualité
d'un comédien nous la portons en nous
quand les lumières du théâtre
s'éteignent elle ne nous quitte pas pour
autant l'émotion du personnage que nous
venons d'interpréter reste la nôtre
c'est pourquoi l'acteur vivra toujours
une double vie cela rejoint d'ailleurs
votre taille sur le dédoublement de la
personnalité
toutes ces questions qui touchent au
mystère même du comédien font de nous
des êtres trop sensible incapable de
supporter les émotions violentes et
c'est ce qui nous rend si vulnérable
heureusement qu'il existe pour nous des
moments rares où le spectacle n'existe
plus où l'on se confond vraiment avec le
rôle que l'on joue notre art c'est notre
vie
si nous cessons de jouer nous cessons de
vivre c'est un métier terrible que le
théâtre commissaire je n'en connais
aucun où la concurrence aussi féroce un
acteur doit plaire il doit séduire à
tout prix alors vous imaginez ce que
peut éprouver un comédien qui se voit
enfin attribuer le rôle de sa vie et que
ce rôle au dernier moment lui échappe
c'est une catastrophe pour lui qui peut
le mener aux pires extrémités même à
tuer
oui même à tuer si ce rôle est celui
d'un assassin il en a organisé en
lui-même une illusion dont il sera la
première victime
l'action de factice deviendra réalité il
aura tellement mais tellement cru à son
personnage qu il s'identifiera à
l'assassin il jouera tragiquement à la
ville son mirage elle a salué le talent
d'artistes commissaire ce n'est jamais
qu'un peu d'enfance qui a réussi à ne
pas mourir
je me rends à vos raisons vous venez de
faire avec infiniment de talent les
loges et la justification de votre
profession vous avez bien compris qu'il
s'agit là d' aveux de théâtre je suppose
que vous ne les prenez pas au sérieux
bon rassurez-vous je viens d'avoir le
rare privilège d'apprécier en privé le
talent d'une remarquable comédienne mais
vous m'avez fait penser à un avocat qui
se serait trompé de client qui je ne
connaissais pas moi même la vérité pour
un peu j'aurais marché parfois nous
sommes deux maintenant à la connaître et
votre nature généreuse vous a même dicté
les circonstances atténuantes dont
pourra bénéficier le véritable coupable
de moselle j'attends toujours vos
révélations concernant ce poudrier
bien oui je suis allé dire bonjour à
monsieur buron et j'ai oublié mon
poudrier cela prouve pas que je sois
coupable
et puis vous voulez vous me dire quels
motifs j'aurais eu de le tuer tu suis la
seule à n'avoir aucun mobile vous l'avez
dit vous-même
quand on veut trouver un mobile
en cherchant bien on en trouve toujours
imaginé par exemple par exemple que
buron en tant que coauteur du film ait
refusé l'engagement de julien commencé
doucement c'est la bc de mon métier sans
et même la routine continent
imaginons que vous soyez allé trouver
buron pour que julien conserve son rôle
qu'il vous en ai fait la promesse et
qu'il se soit rétracté ensuite vous
adorez julien lamour peut tout expliquer
on a commis des crimes beaucoup plus
compliqué pour des motifs beaucoup moins
sérieux c'est comme ça mais c'est
exactement contraire
au cours de cette conversation buron
connaît précisément de m'apprendre que
les producteurs avaient décidé d'engager
d'autres gallo 10 pour garder julian
c'est le disculpe absolument et puis
rassurez vous j'ai jamais douté de votre
innocence
pas vous je ne crois pas souvenez vous
quand vous êtes revenu dans cette pièce
votre directrice vous a fait remarquer
un défaut de maquillage or vous ne
saviez pas où se trouvait la salle de
bain vous l'avez donc refait en
bavardant avec monsieur buron on ne
refait pas son maquillage en présence
d'un mort le cercle de famille se
rétrécit et bien on vous a donné
l'assurance que julien n'avait plus rien
à craindre pour son rôle et vous vous
précipitez pour lui apprendre la bonne
nouvelle
il est maintenant trop tard
à une seconde près caroline éviter la
catastrophe
commissaire commissaire vous m'accusez
vous oubliez que je suis le seul le seul
qui possède un alibi irait fêtards et
irréfutables on va entendu dire mon rôle
dans la bibliothèque sans interruption
votre libye votre arrivée vous allez
voir ce que j'en fais moins de votre
arrivée
aliette s'il vous plaît les etr des
habitants du village sont au comble de
l'indignation et de vengeance alors le
criminel s'en moque
vous n'entendez pas votre voix dans les
pièces a causé en ce moment c'est faux
ce sont tous des photos prouvent et le
peu de patience j'y arrive notre libye
était trop parfait c'est même ça qui m'a
mis la puce à l'oreille
vous adorez caroline c'est vrai mais si
vous l'adorez avec beaucoup d'exclusive
il ya une chose pour laquelle vous
éprouvez une passion des ventes quoi
votre métier
comme l'a si bien dit votre directrice
alors vous étiez vous aviez été monteur
à la télévision vous avait repiqué la
voix de maître sinclair sur la bande de
lindt herviou de ce fameux journaliste
suédois qui n'était autre que vous même
bien entendu seulement quand vous parlez
aux lieu et place d'un académicien
faites attention aux fautes de syntaxe
l'isère commissaire vous me trouvez rien
rien rien vous dites n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi mais demandez tout à
l'heure pourquoi j'étais resté chez vous
dans 22h40 à 11 heures j'attendais que
la pendule de votre cheminée sonnent les
onze coups côté bien de messages
j'entendais le son caractéristique de
votre pendule alors eh oui et oui ne
peut pas penser à tout
vous aviez prévu cette fin triste dans
la réalité mais dans la fiction dans ta
pièce qui est elle coupable
précisément le personnage qu allait
jouer julien oui je l'avais tout de
suite compris et toi aussi julien tu
l'avais senti tu as joué tragiquement à
la ville d'un mirage de la scène
c'est vrai commissaire
j'ai tué
pour conserver un rôle
là
pour conserver ma raison de vivre il
m'en croyez moi vous en supplie je me
suis trompé tout à l'heure j'étais
tellement troublés ce n'est pas ici que
monsieur vire on m'avait appris la
décision des producteurs s'étaient
c'était avant la semaine dernière je
l'avais aussitôt dit à julien tu te
souviens non s'il l'a tué c'est tout
simplement parce que l'idée que j'étais
devenue la maîtresse de bureau le rang
des fous il s'était violemment disputé
le matin même au téléphone à cause de
moi
eh bien on n'est plus là pour vous
contredire mais personne ne pourra
affirmer que vous avez menti et julien
aura tué par passion et par jalousie
c'est un beau cadeau vous lui faites il
pourra plaider le crime passionnel
les jurés sont toujours beaucoup plus
indulgent quand il s'agit d'une histoire
d'amour
la pièce que nous venons de jouer devant
vous et de briquets ray lassegue
le décor et de ranger à
les costumes donne un quart d'heure
la mise en scène dominique non
avec dominique nous
katia tchenko
jean pierre leroux
bernard musson
la carte doit
quatrième à iso
robert matière
dominique paturel
et jacqueline gauthier
enfin